非常榮幸喔 今天我們168X 邀請到 Herman
Herman 是這個前高盛的 FICC 的高管
以及 Zen Family Office 的創辦人
非常榮幸能跟他們168X
我還有我的夥伴 Victor 一起跟 Herman 來做這一場spaces
那首先就有一個問題想問 Herman
就是 因為您之前主要是看 FICC嘛
然後也會用宏觀的這種 Macro 的角度來看 Bitcoin 的股票這些資產
那在現在這個局勢來說
2026年這個 Semiconductor 的大牛市之中
你覺得目前市場流動性會怎麼走
然後對於接下來一年這個美股也好 或是幣圈也好
市場走勢這邊大概怎麼辦
嗯 流動性這個東西呢 我覺得本來按特別長時間
就是 Liquidity 的東西 你要 keep monitoring 一直要看著的
然後我先說一下我對那個流動性看法
然後關於三月份到現在這個流動性的走勢
其實我們去年六月份的時候
其實講過就是 ESLR 這些會結榜
然後整體市場流動性相對來說是會比較寬暈
因為你回頭看就是說 ESLR 這些影響
其實在最近你看市場流動性應該已經都看得出來的
Soft Rate 一直比較低嗎
然後Soft Rate 比較低的同時
那個整個 Market Lending
Soft Rate那個 Merri Market Lending 的3.1萬億左右
3.1萬億去年大概是在每天北壘
然後去年的話 2.9 到 3 之間吧
那你其實看到今年的流動性相對來說是比較寬暈
這是一些指標
然後同時的話你可以去比較一下
比方說我上週好像也說到過的一個
就比方說你的 Turn Premium 減去你的Soft Rate
這可能是更加Technical一些東西
Soft Rate 那個其實代表你去養一個債券
像是用短期的利率去養一個債券
然後能夠養到多少利息
那這些Soft Rate 相對來說現在都處於比較低的
包括五年十年都是比較低的位置
那麼這個意思就是市場在銀行端的流動性
相對來說是比較寬暈的
然後寬暈流動性的情況下
你要把流動性吸掉的話
現在短期來看的話
要通過比方說Trash去發展
那這些東西是可以把流動性吸掉的
我們看到發展的規模在 Caller 2 還是比較少的
我可能晚一點我到你下面我去發兩圖吧
就 Caller 2 的話
你可以看它那個流動性還相對來說是比較少
那就不是發展 發展規模還是比較少
那就意味著市場上的流動性可能還是會保持比較寬暈
但是7月份以後發展的規模是上去的
但是這不代表流動性要直接逆轉
因為你看5月6號的時候
Secretary General Bousin
Secretary Bousin 說的一句話
就是說我現在要把發展的要維護市場流動性的穩定
所以我要把Trash rate 重新去放 repo
然後意思就是我這個正常你發展是從 Bank Reserve
就是從那個銀行裡面把錢給取出來發到國債
然後國家把這個錢放到財政部的帳戶時代
也出來自在 Fed Reserve 放到 Fed Reserve 把流動性吸掉
他也要把它放過去
那其實我覺得對於白宮 白宮的意思是比較明確的
就是我其實這是一個態度問題
我不大在乎流動性很多
我也不大在乎因為流動性很多可能會產生泡沫
那我們現在對於市場流動性的態度就是希望它更多
然後對於市場我覺得要漲
就是我要讓它漲
這個是一個我覺得是個 signal
並沒有這麼明確的去講
但是我從它的這個資理行件或者是它一些表態上
我覺得它是這樣一個態度
那然後我補充幾個就關於 Fed 的事情
Fed 今天應該是今天吧
好像他要去說
因為我這兩天沒有特別注意
我還是覺得
就是 At the end of the day 最後
美國回頭看 2008 年到 2012 年這個週期
它是銀行把監管慢慢加上去
然後銀行監管加上去的過程中間
它一直在做 QE
做 QE 就放出流動性
然後銀行的 multiple 這成倍再減少
因為銀行的 leverage 再減少
那這個過程是走了挺長週期的
然後你現在那個週期是說
其實一個理性的週期
應該是要么你慢慢把那個監管給放開
然後流動性反噬出來
要么你就做 QT 然後把那個監管給放開
我覺得它可能想走第二步路
就是包括現在 Fed 講到的 QT
包括 Fed 講到我要降息再加 QT
然後它做不做 QT 我都不知道
然後這可能是想走第二條路
因為你的銀行的監管
把流動性釋放在放在那個銀行裡面
其實花了比較長的時間完成這個週期
你需要在 ESLR 裡面一下子給它解綁
特別是比較嚴不光是改了比率的問題
主要的是把那個 risk-based capital
把那個國債從分母裡面給它直接去的
所以其實我們可以隨便去養國債了
我們可以直接去投國債
這問題不是投國債
而是整個錢的流動在銀行間裡會變得更多
然後銀行可以持有國債然後做 collateral
這整個流動性就是因為這個東西是個 multiple
所以會有四萬 狗們預期之前是四萬五千億吧
好像四萬五千億美元的這個可投資產
就是可以增加銀行的
增加銀行的那個就是什麼
那個 explosion 可以增加這麼多
實際增加可能在一萬五到兩萬
因為銀行會分紅嘛
但畢竟它現在沒有分
然後現在也沒有完全把那個 leverage 給 build up
所以我們這個就更紅完一點
我說的稍微微觀一點
就是我們在過去幾個星期裡面看到的
特別是其實過去兩到三個星期裡面看到的
是一個 leverage up
就市場通過 leverage up 的辦法就剛趕
增加剛趕增加流動性
然後把這個市場給former 起來
回過去看在
因為我們說 ESLR 的放開是在去年12月
應該在4月1號全部試試
然後我們看到在12月在3月份的時候
整個市場沒有漲
所以 CTA 的倉位全部開始要調整
CTA 是隊長沙爹的嘛
它有 short and CTA, long and CTA
然後 mid and CTA 和 long and CTA
同時的話也有很多 ball control strategy
這個掉在一起叫 systematic position
就 systematic strategy
這 systematic strategy 在3月31號前三個星期
賣了 1800 億 global 全球
賣了 1800 億
所以這個其實導致了我們
因為當然有伊朗的問題了
其實我覺得之前沒有漲得動
然後加上 CTA
這個是疊殺了在伊朗的事情上
但是在那個時間上
這個跌幅比我在春節之後
預期要少很多
確實要少很多
那主要問題我覺得就是
主要的原因是
Semic and Delta 固執實在太低
就 Semic and Delta 比方說英偉大
英偉大業就增長了 70%
在180塊錢的時候
和去年90塊錢是沒有區別的
所以整個 Semic
你覺得它最近漲了很兇
但是它其實是在4月份的時候
整體固執
4月之前整體固執被壓制了
沒有漲起來
這個好像我在YouTube上在
在對對上反覆講過這種事情
但是從3月31號之後三個星期
第一個星期買了800 億
第二星期買了400 億還500 億
然後後面是買了300多億
然後這個是 CTA
那到 CTA 在兩到三個星期之內已經不重要了
這個東西不對市場當中很大影響
但是把它拉回來主要是 CTA 拉的
那 CTA 拉回來的時候
那市場真正 FOMO 的是什麼
兩件事情
第一件事情是 FOMO 了半導體
然後半導體固執低
第二個其實 FOMO 是 Anthropic
Anthropic 那個時候就是很紅
然後大家也知道模型有用
就是 FOMO 了
我們認為 AGI 已經實現
確實我這個是認可的
所以最果的就是把半導體給先炒起來
然後在後面幾個星期
其實市場流動性很寬宇
一直很寬宇
我們看到其實你別看國債的利率在上升
國債利率上升中間有開始 pricing
就特別是長端
有一些 pricing 的通脹
通脹的預期油價上升
然後打上不確定性
但是本身你看銀行間的流動性
就銀行間流動性
你看 Soveread
然後再看 Financial Condition Index
那這些東西都是比較寬宇的
所以我把這一輪上漲分成兩部分
第一部分叫做強買
強買就是你一開始強買的銷率是最高的
我說錯了
一開始是400億
第二個星期是800億
然後第三個星期是300億
漲得最兇的是一開始400億
因為拉盤的話
你肯定是一開始的錢效果最好
然後把石頭拉起來的時候
整個市場還是 FOMO 了
所以第二階段是整個市場 FOMO
那它的本質是
半導體在
我覺得在前一段壓制的過程中間
它的固執實在太低了
然後對於它的增長
對於它的這個敘事和
我們看到在那個 Enthalpig 的這個模型
模型的成功
這些東西上來看的話
它就是固執比較低
所以是結合流動性在一起來看
然後往後面看流動性
這個很難看很長時間了
就我剛剛講
那我只能說到6月前
流動性還是可以的
就是整個銀行金的流動性肯定還是可以的
然後現在市場
市場當情緒上來的時候
你可以
你可以覺得它固執有點貴
然後或者它情緒太高
可以退出一些
那我其實也賣掉一些
我一直在賣
我也賣費了不少
然後當然我沒有權賣掉
但是千萬不要去做碰它
特別是在那個流動性不確定
流動性可能比較好的時候
我說一個假設
然後這件事情
我一直在考慮有可能會有個會調
然後這個會調不會
它不大會在馬上
但是不是馬上要崩盤時的會調
不是
但是我覺得在今年年底
或者明年年初
它會有一輪可能會
不應會發生
可能會有一輪比較迷你佛的會調
就是華爾街到現在
我一直是不太相信
那個半導體
整個半導體行業
然後我覺得從去年才開始相信
就基本上也之前不太相信
那現在最後的質疑在哪裡
最後的其實質疑在
anthropic open eye
他們是不是左腳踩右腳
然後
是不是左腳踩右腳
就是你你的錢是融來的
然後你把這個錢融來
錢再畫到那個csp上面去了
然後但是真正給他們花錢的
那幾個hyperscale
他的cash flow開始
就free cash flow開始變少
然後同時的話
你可以看
我當我這個你提醒我一下
我也可以發上來
就是看一下那個cds
其實從去年
我覺得24年的增長是
20年的股市最最健康
那時候包括那個
microsoft的cds
跟銀行是一樣比銀行低
就基本上是零
然後但是現在的話
你整體的cds平均上了15個點吧
對
所以
但你hyperscale
你不能看那個Oracle
那個是單公司
它上了很多
但是所有hyperscale
包括從meta開始
那些hyperscale的cds
都在都在慢慢往上跑
就是有沒有可能醞釀一個回調
那我覺得是有這個可能性的
因為在那個時間點上
它會疊加
我們現在油價上漲
導致經濟衰退
不是衰退吧
經濟變弱
因為油價這個東西
跟tariff跟關稅
沒有什麼特別大本質的區別的
就是相當於收了一個稅
然後這個稅
它會在6到至少6個月吧
它有Lagin會影響通脹
因為我們不看非核心的CPI的
所以直接油價上漲
我們是不看的
但是它連鎖的反應在比方說
不管那個看的是中間價
就比方說
那個camel watch看的是中間價
還是看什麼
它現在還是看pce
然後這個中間的這些pce
被連帶上來是需要時間傳導的
然後包括GDP也是需要時間傳導
所以當我們如果面臨經濟看上去
沒有那麼好
現在經濟還比較好嗎
然後就業再下去
因為業業或不因為業業
就業都會下去
然後再加上這些大公司free cash flow
它如果產生共振
我覺得這個共振感覺蠻大的
就是可能會產生共振
那這個時候呢
會重新有一輪
對Sami-Connector對AI的這些質疑
這個我覺得可能會晚一點時候會發生
這個這種回調
如果發生這種事情的回調
我會去像現在怎麼熊食一天兩天
一個星期兩星期
我覺得至少幾個月吧
但是如果是那種事情發生的話
那我覺得還是堅決的買進去
因為我對Sami-Connector對半導體
我待會可以根據你後面的話題
我不想你一個話題說太久
就是說我根據你後面的話題
可以來說我對於半導體
然後對於整個AI
我覺得現在方興AI
剛剛開始就是第一段的節奏
Beginning of the end
Oh sorry, end of beginning
太剛開始
那既然都講到了這個半導體
這個可不可以請Herman哥跟大家分享一下
為什麼那麼看好這個光訊
CPU這一類的股票
哦
為什麼看好CPU
我可以先說幾句
為什麼看好半導體
就是半導體
因為我覺得這個是從上往下面去講
就是這樣子
從半導體這個事情
就是說我們過去40年
過去至少40年
就是包括我們從00年的科技革命
你後面好像有問題
問00年科技革命跟現在差別
我就突出來先說一下這個話
就是說00年科技革命和現在的差別是什麼
00年科技革命的使用率很低
現在的使用率很高
包括當時的這個
你鋪的海底光藍的使用率低得不得了
你不要說這個東西
那怕現在在5G的激戰裡面
就5G的激戰的電的使用率
大概5%到10%
所以它的那個compatibility沒有那麼強
也就是其實最本質的東西是
從我們上一輪互聯網科技革命
其實背後用的是半導體
但是半導體的提高
並沒有直接產生生產力
半導體的提高是變成了一個軟件的平臺
讓人可以在上面開發軟件開發App
然後使用軟件和使用App的人
產生了生產力
或者是產生了虛假的
或真實的生產力這些東西
比方說你設計
設計一個東西
然後你把這個東西去發爆發到中國
中國可能兩毛錢給你加工掉了
但是你這裏又去買了谷歌的流量
你作為大隊的marketing協議對PPT
那全是價值
然後這些價值加1700美金
然後這一百美金是基於
我們現在軟件開發平臺的
所以這個我好像寫過一個推的
我寫了一個故事
寫挺好玩
反正大概就是這意思
就是你在上面本質上
所有做的半導體
其實並不是直接生產生產力的
但是OPPO 4.6
至少從OPPO 4.6開始吧
包括我最近用的5.5
你是讓半導體直接形成生產力了
形成生產力
那就是就和真跡級革命
我們以前只發生過兩次
一次真跡級革命
可能內然跡革命吧
然後就內然跡和石油的革命
這個是直接是數據的話
那真跡級你能夠
你能夠生產什麼樣的效率
那你就能夠生產多少衣服
那個東西都是數據
所以我們長期來精英主義
為什麼精英主義呢
因為一切東西都是實踐
客觀可檢驗
我們美國西方以前
基礎教育數學也是很好的
不是只有中國人搞這些東西
只是我們這幾年的脫石就虛了
就是上面這些東西太多了
以至於我們基礎的東西
可能被一些被遺忘
但是半導體本質上
它變成了直接變成了生產力
這是過去40年第一次
第二個原因
這是第一個
就是它本身的重要性
是在核心的
而不是軟件
而不是那些工作的人
或者是資訊公司
或者是那些幫你設計的設計公司
不是這些東西
它變化了
然後第二個
這是第一個原因
第二個就是
我覺得是整個半導體行業
包括你們臺灣的台積電為主
不相信AI
所以在2023年到現在
它沒有對AI進行大規模的
開拍次的投入
因為AI是可見的
我看到有大量半導體需求的東西
從台積電的晶圓廠到封裝
你可以知道封裝廠
它其實是要手搓的
你這個產能是提不上去的
對吧
然後到
包括我們先看到存儲的這個產能
包括我們看到
甚至像光歸的那些產能
和甚至到最後的原材料的產能
全部沒有提上去
就是這個沒有提上去的背後
是其實整個半導體行業
它是一個看頭部的行業
這個頭部看的產能是台積電
台積電不擴
誰也不敢擴
然後
ASMO也不敢擴
所有人都不敢擴
台積電在過去三年
對台積電過去三年裡面比較保守
所以它的保守
導致了我們產能的智候至少三年
但是即使今天的投入
它是遠遠遠遠不夠的
因為我們會看到
token的真正的需求
它能夠幹得活
就是它的token的需求
那這些token的需求
其實是在供應端的
其實我現在看起來是無限的
但是你在那個
不是供應端說錯了
我在需求端是無限的
但是在supply side
那個台積電的
就包括台積電
包括所有人家一起
他們的產能供應還是比較保守
因為今天你投的產能
也需要很長時間才能夠出來
那我們就說回到你剛才講的問題
就是光和為什麼看好光
看好光這個問題有點麻煩了
因為這看好光
我待會還要去說一下存儲的事情
那我就先說一下光
就是說大致的一個數字
英偉達的MV720那個那個RAC裡面
那個RAC裡面
CPU的金額大概是10%
然後GPU完全是40
採購的金額
然後那個存儲現在30
因為存儲長得比較多
但是存儲繼續長
還有變高
光是20%
然後光所有公司的市值加起來
沒有美光高
這個就是這是一個比較
比較fundamental的business
但這裡面講的
講的這個我講的很粗文做
因為美光有很多東西DDR的
它不光是這個
它有75%以上的出乎是DDR
那我只是覺得在存儲裡面
DDR不太能夠去拿那個PE的估值
所以按照合理的估值來看的話
我就覺得在光的
光的份額和它的市值
整體的市值都要上去
然後因為Tinspace有很多很專業的
然後有很多不太專業的
然後我就給你們一個人比較多
我就說一下不太專業的說法
你就相當於現在在建數據中心
你在建數據中心
這個是規模化的巨大的鐵高
因為需求很大
就好像你一個城市在城鎮化一樣
你城鎮化的時候你就需要
樓這樣更高了
你就需要電梯對吧
那電梯就是scaling
然後樓和樓的通道
就scale up
對 然後階區和階區就是scale out
然後城市和城市就scale cross
這些東西都要用光的
從scale cross本來就是用光的
然後到scale in到scale up
這個過程是光不停的在拓展
往下的應用就越來越細越有心
因為原來全是用銅
就是越進的越用銅
它其實是一個不但在市場增長
同時的話
它在吃市場份額的一個business
所以在這裡面是絕對受益的
包括你看谷歌的新的TPU的方案
它可能增加兩倍的光的需求
那這個也是很確定
增加兩倍的光的需求
後面每一代其實都要增加
就像這個東西像你基建一樣
它就會繼續增加
然後光和存儲都會缺
然後會缺很久很久
就是都我看不到
至少我們現在投資版
今天不是持個五年十年
你基本上也就看不到它那個需求
我們就不是賣房市場
就估計也看不到
那都在缺的時候
我在光和存儲裡面會去選光的原因是
我Sum號覺得存儲還是有很強的商品性
商品性的意思就是
你很難給一個石油公司PE的估值
不知道你名不來這個意思
就不太能夠給一個石油公司PE的估值
但是你在CPU、GPU和光的這個產品上面
它每個產品都是不一樣
它就是有產品性
然後有疊帶
然後光還有一個好處
就是說其實比方說
它從800G到1.6T
這樣的疊帶的過程當中
它其實疊帶導致了
它在增加它的毛利率
在增加它的收入
就是我疊帶我800G
肯定1.6T 800G兩倍
那我的錢也得兩倍多
但是我採購的零配件
有些零配件是差不多的
所以我的零配件差不多的情況下
我只是Wafer那可以變貴了
那我的Margin是一直在提高的
你知道我意思嗎
毛利率是來提高的
所以我只是不需要在擴產的時候
我就可以做到提高毛利率
我是產品
我提高毛利率
然後提高收入
這個是
而且是定存的很快
所以這個市場就是整個市場
我覺得對於不同的player是有
這個如果要講到這個市場player
可能要講很久
就是裡面有好多好多比較低
我可能私下背帶後再問我
然後但是我覺得在這個裡面
就是
對於半導體是因缺進去
全部要缺貨
然後對於光的公司是因買進買
就你都買
都無所謂的
差不多都不會太差
特別抽象的
你可以稍微
稍微保守一點
但是對於一般的來說
我覺得基本上
我對於是這樣的一個態度
所以這個是
我為什麼比較看好光
了解
那如果說你說光
我們說深入一點
你說像比如說AOI
或是LIT
這一些在做CPO的公司
這個大概
reprime個
你怎麼看這些
企業他們的優勝裂敗
單N票呢
我很難去推薦這個事情
我在對這裏一直講這個概念
就是一項
比如說AOI
我們買的成本實在太低了
所以你讓我現在在市場
現在這個價錢
我就想說去看好它
或者補看好它
就是會壓力比較大
因為AOI公司
跟我們其實有
比較深的淵源的
說句老實話
他當年做CB的時候
一塊六的時候
我們就有接觸
跟這公司很髒
然後當時結算完
當時9000萬的公司
對
換點破產
因為他在中國
在產能
中國那個時候Covid
把他產能給停了
他差點破產
國內產能沒了
但是我說到光的AOI
或者是其他都是一樣的
我覺得在Semiconductor
一個比較通用的方法
是來衡量公司
是他過去幾年有沒有投產
有沒有做CAPEX
OSPE是非常討厭CAPEX的
所以你在CAPEX的過程中
大概一定是把你的事業給當掉
然後AOI過去
是確實做了不少的CAPEX
對吧
然後我就不說了
他在哪裡 對吧
他寧波可能有廠
然後在美國有廠
然後他在做CAPEX
在做CAPEX過程中
就是會得到受益
然後他在光上是
哎呀 這個公司
我不太想去公開講
他太多好不好
然後他這個公司其實
是這樣子
就是我只能這樣講
就是他的創始人
講的每一句話都是 decent
然後他跟我們
在當年最最早的時候
23年的時候說的東西
24年預期是沒有達到
大午年確實是達到的
就是他是這樣的
就是他的方向是沒有錯
只是他話說的會很慢
但是問題是
你在這個投產
和這個新產品領路的過程中間
你確實有很多的容錯
所以呢
他在沒有容錯的時候
經常會miss expectation
就這個公司miss expectation
太容易了
就這個是性格實然
但是呢
他方向肯定是沒有什麼問題的
但是這個太
就是這個公司太早
就是那個怎麼說呢
就是我們跟了太早
嗯 了解了解
不過剛剛
Hermann哥講一個
就是說以前華爾街是
很不喜歡CAPEX
那現在他反而是
他想看你CAPEX
他想看你這個資本利用效率
看你到底投產之後
多快有一個return
那其實剛剛Hermann哥有提
你說台積電
我上禮拜六這個
在台北東區
跟台積電的那個
專門擴廠的
這個工程師
跟他喝酒
結果他就說
他說A
他說他們現在
基本上這個
這個擴廠
他真的是在
比如說在台灣
他在新竹寶山那一代
或是說台南好了
他們那個真的是在
造橋俘路的在
就是建造一整個
就是開發一個
一個位置的區域
這個我覺得
Very amazing
這個Hermann哥
可以跟大家來聊一下
說對於CAPEX電視劇
這些Semminton
到這個時候
是的
是你在台北看
你也可以去鳳凰城看一下
鳳凰城那個沙漠中的城市
幾百個高爾夫球場
對啊
也很大
就是CAPEX這個東西
就是說
包括當時
你看今年
比較爆發的幾個票
包括ALI
包括還有Intel
都是以前搞CAPEX
搞得很猛的
差點沒把自己搞死
就Intel是個
最最標誌差點沒把
自己搞死
但是這個Semminton
到這個CAPEX
就是需要很長的時間
那個
我覺得CAPEX這個事情
來幾方面
看去華爾街現在
華爾街原來是
非常討厭CAPEX
所有東西討厭CAPEX
包括AUROCO
也是一個
因為CAPEX
CDS搞得很高
但是這為什麼呢
因為華爾街喜歡
喜歡藥廠
就喜歡我
軟件公司這樣
我做了一個
軟件
然後可以賣給所有人
然後我每一次
賣出去以後
我的拍貨其實
不花多少錢
對吧
我只是開發花錢
然後我後面的
運圍花的錢
也是比較少
就是小頭
所以我可以這樣
不停地Leverage
我拿到很高的毛疹
這個是輕模式
然後做設計公司
也是個輕模式
他喜歡這些東西
就華爾街的過去
我們叫我們
整體經濟拖時向虛
就是向了這些虛的東西
然後實的東西
就是稍微高端
放給台灣人
然後就拉激火
Pattern火
就是丟給大陸
然後大陸
就兩毛錢給你敲了
台積電的
那個新竹那裏
就幹這個經驗
不好意思
我沒有那個意思
但是就差不多
是這個這個idea
對吧
但是現在
我覺得有一個風向
大家要非常注意的
就是包括在Google在內
大量的美國
就最Top的那些
這個Silicon Valley
那些大的hyperscale
這些公司
已經realized
已經認識到
我們的輕模式
會被改變
我們以後必須要用這種模式
就是might token的模式
叫token工廠
就就Jinson講的
那個token工廠的模式
就是我
我用軟件
並不是我把軟件給他弄一遍
然後去賣無數個
無數個Pattern
而是說
我通過跟他的infra
不停的在might token
那如果是might token
你變成了一個工廠
那你就一定要注重
要做capacity
你不做capacity
有沒有產能
這件事情
我覺得
這是為什麼
我覺得今年在
今年年底晚一點
到明年年初
還有可能
會有市場
一個比較大的
下調的原因
就是華爾街這個腦子
沒有完全搬過來
就是capacity多了
free cash flow
然後有問題
他的腦子
沒有完全搬過來
但是
Pineer
真正了解市場的
比方說Larry
Oracle他們
他就是非常
非常有決心的
在做投入
因為他不在乎
他知道這個
一定是未來
就是我們一定
會變成一個工廠模式
變成工廠模式之後
所有的公司
看幾個點
就是第一個
你看你過去有沒有投入
那你今天有沒有產能
你今天能不能賣出去的東西
看你過去有沒有投
那你未來
能不能賺錢
取決於你投入的
投入產投產比
好不好
我們在增新的那個金圓廠
我朋友在增新的那個金圓廠
他們到fonding
6個月
那比你台灣還要快
就非常恐怖
因為你知道金圓廠
下面不是要弄一個很高的
440幾米的那個地基
還多大一個地基
弄個很大的來地基
剪這樣的這些東西
所以
所以你要是在fonding
機器沒裝進去
他可能只有6個月
在全球
英特爾在美國你敢來多久
那當然
鳳凰城不能同比
用鳳凰城基建沒有
但是就是
投產比
投產的速度
和投產的
就是投產比
這個決定於公司
未來的這個價值
在哪裡投
能夠產出投入更快
所以從這個角度上來講
你說英特爾能夠超過
那個TSMC
那些不大可能
這個在短期裡
反正是看不到的
就是英特爾是有我長期
跟很看好
我覺得他估值低
然後有各方面的原因
但是
最近有人在說
他能超台積電
那我覺得這個天方業壇
這個早著的
了解
那如果說
你說華爾街
現在腦子還沒整過來
那
這個過渡期會長怎麼樣
還有是
會是什麼樣的
一個契機
讓華爾街搞懂說
現在其實
就是要high capex
這個是
有什麼樣的
契機會觸發這個點
我覺得會有兩種
第一種就是調整性的
第二種就是自然性的
因為這個確實
我們也沒有辦法知道
市場到底會怎麼走
調整性的
那就是
跌
跌完
覺得這些capex
好的就比方說
我們現在New Cloud
Cloud那邊就是調整性的
我知道Oracle
你2028年這個20會出來
然後
現金流會變好
你現在沒有
你在做capex
我先把你CDS打上去
因為capex
你要花錢
那你CDS就先上去
你借了再多CDS上去
然後我就把你股價殺下來
殺了很低
然後不讓你被迫在
底部用股票去融資
你完成融資以後
打不動了
對吧
發現你比方說
我覺得很有可能
Oracle在後面
幾個季度的業績就不錯
然後就覺得
反彈了
就是你果然你開始拿到
你capex出去以後
開始收錢了
那再給你股值
這種就調整性
然後有的時候
市場會本身
比方說對Amazon類似
Amazon也在做capex
那又看你capex的比率
就像你剛剛講
就是你投產比怎麼樣
是吧
然後你投產以後
有沒有
漲份額
有沒有賺錢
你是Amazon
你還是Microsoft
對
這就不太一樣
這是有不同的可能性的
所以我並不說
Route說今年
就是這個調整是
一定會發生
I never said it
但是我只是說
就有可能
會給機會的
我說給機會
因為我對半導體的
這個指尖生產力
這件事情
我是非常convicted
然後我覺得
時間會很長
了解
那如果你說這個生產力
就是說
現在半導體
是直接給大家
產出這種很大的
proactivity
那你覺得說
這個美股
未來
尤其是Q3 Q4
可能會有
很大的這個流動性黑洞
因為
不一定
你說股票是吧
對
這幾個大的IPO的deal
那對電信
你怎麼看
到時候
美股
就是它是能承接
IPO的流動性嗎
還是會爆胎
not when to see
就是
如果說
要爆胎的話
時間也跟我
剛剛講的幾件事情
是重疊的
就是我剛剛講的
事情和
這個是重疊的
甚至你現在
別說其他的
你伊朗的
那個海峽
你到現在沒打開嗎
所以
所以這個確實是有風險
我們沒有經歷過
這麼大的IPO和IP
不免可能會拋
就
可能會
那個老股賣出來了
就是那個
可能套現
但是同時的話
我覺得還有一個點
可以考慮的是說
歐伯亞和很多北歐
他們覺得他上市
家會跌
歐伯定會上
他們現在也沒有那麼缺錢
所以這也是一種可能性
就是
包括你現在看
幣圈有一些莫名其妙的
把他的股票
在鏈上賣了賣去
然後人家也不讓你賣
對吧
這些印度
就是
二級的印度
對
半導體
或對整個市場影響
會很大
因為現在
半導體的比率
越來越高了
你再下去
到70了
然後你
如果你
如果
你
如果出了一點風吹
炒凍
讓他
只要二級市場
這麼跌一下
整個市場
要給你
他的聯動性
太好了
現在市場
相對來說
我未必再說
Openinga和Andopia上市
要小心
因為
現在市場
比較好的是
兩個
第一個產能和Margin
這一邊
台積電是
整個半導體的
守門員
然後他不過產
就導致了大家的
Margin都很高
然後後面
Margin一致很高
然後第二個
就是Andopia和Openinga
他補上市
所以他的那個
你沒有辦法
聯動他們的
財務數據
然後說
你這個左腳踩有腳
或者你自己他
確實很好
然後
Revenue一直在增加
增加了很快
所以
你這段被隔絕了
你整個美股
是看著
這個中間的一塊
在潮拜導體
那這個過程
其實是最最
最最舒適的
但如果你假設
今天Andopia上市了
然後Openinga
也是上市的
一家是兩萬億
一家兩萬億
然後這兩家公司
今天有個模型
比方說
沒有收斂好
或者是Andopia
因為你
終究有巨大的
需求差
你萬一沒有達到預期
或者因為算力
不足
沒有達到預期假設
那或者
你覺得你這個效果下降
前兩時間
不說那個4.6的那個
上下文在介紹
那股價下跌的話
他會導致
所有東西一起控制
那這個就是會
就是可以發生很大的
很大的變化
那現在的時間點
我就來
可以了
然後不單是你
剛剛講的兩家
還有SpaceX
你要上市
所以這三個
西的流動性會很大
就是我們確實
會有這個風險
But on the other hand
我們現在銀行間的流動性
還是比較寬裕的
就是整個
在美國的
紅瓜流動性是比較寬裕的
Financial Condition
是很寬裕的
然後
但是同時的話
你要這個水
水池很深
你要穿裡面
去肉很多水
然後去肉水以後
還會和市場
現在共振
然後經濟有可能
會比較差
然後華爾街
不一定完全認
Heavy Capax
所以我覺得
後面
有Turbulence的概率蠻大的
所以我稍微總結一下
荷爾門哥你的意思
你意思說
基本上現在
大家是
市場是處於一種
萌龍美的狀態
因為你opening
說你不上市
你不上市
那
大家就不知道
你財報
你到底多賺錢
你margin怎麼樣
你存
這個叫什麼
profit
存利怎麼樣
那一旦知道了
哎
這就
這就很像泡牛
就是一個nil
就是
他還沒脫下衣服裤子的時候
可能是最性感
但脫光了
就完蛋了
爆胎了
他其實
他其實跟
他跟半ipo沒有區別
就是他們的這個數據
都是公開的
就是現在因為
他已經對了
很多機構投資人
這些數據大家都知道
但只是沒有得到
足夠的重視
沒有得到散戶
情緒面的
足夠的重視
等到他得到了
重視的時候
會把他的瑕疵給放大的
而且他的預期
會越來越高
因為anthropic
今年的表現
太好了
所以預期越來越高
然後這麼高的預期
他一定會失望的
你失望的原因
不是你模型
是算力不夠
但是市場
第一個解讀
他不會是算力不夠
他一定解讀是
這個模型不行
但其實是算力不夠
比方說4.6
你說他失智
他是失智嗎
他沒有算力給你用
其實這個
額外衍生一下
因為我記得有一次
我跟Harman哥分享
我說
OPER 4.7
我是覺得
是比GPT 5.5還好用
就Harman哥
你就說
GPT 5.5
你說
你叫我不要
不要太八眼
不要太偏見
Harman哥
你要不要跟大家來
分享一下
你目前使用的
這幾個模型
用起來的個子
怎麼樣
我覺得5.5
相對來說
Codex 5.5好用一點
然後特別是在
長上壓紋的時候
然後他去做那些
planning
更好一點
我覺得這個
somehow to do
somehow有一個原因
是可能
OPER 5的算力比較充足
相對
很多別的算力比較充足
4.6剛剛用的時候
效果也很好
因為我們用來
直接做生產機的東西
我就做那個
Porto的高頻
然後Crypto高頻
你下單的速度
你2 ohm
1.4 ohm
然後當然我們會做很多
AWS的優化
優化除外
其實你的
包括你程序
會不會併發那些東西
也是立馬可以
獲得證反饋
就跟比方說
你是做個網頁
或做個遊戲
那個東西不一定
馬上獲得證反饋
我們做交易的馬上
證反饋
我交易一天
幾萬筆交易
甚至更多
那些東西
有幾筆出問題
後台怎麼維護
這些全線全部誰來的
我們現在程序
可能有95%左右
都是延期的吧
然後有一小部分
其實很少的
基本上全部是延期
然後
4.6和5.5
我的感受是
5.5可能
就是剩下粉的時候
更好點
如果要用4.6
就是要用5.5
做完Planning
然後把它寫到
一個文道裡去
然後把那個
所有他這個問題
要調用的那個
skill
導MDN的這些東西
全部告訴那個
4.6
4.7
然後讓4.7寫
它效果也還可以
但是就上下文的那塊
我個人感覺
我可能會更好
那5.6
我是確實是很經驗的
就是我的
我決定要用一下效果
很不錯
但是你人多
你再這麼用下去
能不能繼續維持
我也不知道
這對
因為你
你最後能
你最後這個模型
大家用了還是
最後就是看叔叔token
他還給你砍掉一些
上下文
給你砍掉一些
deep thinking
就這個是沒有
辦法的事情
因為他算力不夠
了解
那既然剛剛
Herman哥你都提到
B圈了
Viktor
Viktor在嗎
嗨
哈囉
Yo
來Viktor
你來跟
Herman哥
我們來跟Herman哥
請教一下這個
BTU
MS
BTN的問題
好啊
好
我是Viktor
然後
Crypto這一塊
其實
我蠻早就
一直在followHerman哥
對Crypto的看法
然後我記得你當初
一開始2024年
應該是2024年初開始
經營這個帳號
然後
當時就是
定位就是在
Explore
就是Blockchain和Crypto
然後你一直提到說
其實
看好BTC
然後
會一直持有BTC
然後你在今年初的時候
其實也有提到說
黃金白銀的掌勢是有
地緣政治的泡沫
但是
股票和美人是沒有問題
然後BTC是不怕泡沫
然後
你那時候也有提到說
當時必安
有出一個就是
這是買入BTC
買入BTC的
B金
然後你說必安屯
那麼
你也可以繼續買
沒有沒有
我開玩笑的
不要得罪必安
她是我藝術父母
不是
我們交易都在必安上
大部分交易
在必安上
我不去說她
但是
不是因為她說
我是說
幣圈的人都去炒黃金
那炒黃金
你們都去炒黃金的
黃金肯定不好了
我入了一次
對
沒錯
那麼我比較好奇的就是
以你
做家族辦公室的角度
然後對於BTC
你們會怎麼看待
BTC作為資產配置的一部分
然後為什麼你會
一直強調說
BTC是值得
就是長期持有的資產
我說一下BTC看法
整個Crypto的看法
然後說一下我們在做什麼
其實我們現在
家族辦公室管的
都是我個人的錢
就是我們個人的錢
就是我們兩個合夥人的
個人錢
然後我們
一個是在Crypto上面
做的是高頻
然後在股票上做投資
所以沒有
怎麼對外募資
然後
因為是自己的錢
所以我們投資
就打名字比較大
比方說
BTC跌的時候
我們就比較敢買
買了就是比較肯拿
包括我們很多股票投資
因為我是從Crypto
每天能夠賺到錢走的
那我賺到錢走
我就拿著這個錢
就一直在投股票
然後股票
如果跌我也不care
因為我也不插這個錢
去幹嘛
然後我們還會
一直有點心情的去投
所以是這樣一個狀態
所以我覺得
就好像給投資嘛
你要是知道
你是管一個Portfolio的話
你在跌的時候
你沒有辦法忍住
你必須要清倉
或者要
要撿
要防毀車啊
是不是的
但是我們好像是
沒有這個需求
因為我們是相當於
是cash flow
加上deposit
然後deposit
只是把它deposit
在一些
風險資產上
所以我們會持
我們跟著拿得住
就跌的時候
長的時候有時候
不見拿不住
這是有的
但是跌的時候
我們非常拿得住
特別是我們很convicted asset
但是becoin是這樣子
becoin
我其實
很早買過
在兩三萬的時候買過
但是我確實在吃飯的時候
給它全賣掉
然後
那個時候
買賣掉以後
我基本上
還是那個時候
是買了美股
就美股我們一直在買
在這一輪下跌的時候
但中間
我們做這麼多的交易
我們在邊上
現在很低了
現在一天交易大概只有
兩億不到
兩億美元不到
之前
之前多很多
因為現在流動性太差了
然後
然後每個交易所
我們都在做
像現在
就是即使如此
我從來不買becoin
就是在
它漲到十幾萬十二萬
我一點都不行
我從來不買
然後
它下跌六萬多
七萬以內我買過
然後買了也沒有動
一直放著
能放著那一隻
我覺得是一個SL Location
對我來講是
對我們來講
是SL Location
畢竟我們還做一些Crypto交易
然後這些becoin
也可以放在
帳戶裡面做Clarro
也不影響
反正放著也放著
就這種態度
但是你說
我特別太不看好becoin
一定會怎麼樣
我沒有這麼
我覺得
becoin長期來說
是個流動性對沖
所以
長期來說
是一個
可以看好的資產
但沒有說
像我們
但是你也不能把
所有錢
全部放在
所以我就放一些becoin
然後那個時候
至少正好跌得比較兇
所以買了一些
becoin這個東西
本質
為什麼買becoin
有沒有買其他的
第一個
我對幣圈
所有的鏈
我都不大認可
就是
它更多的東西
其實這些東西都是神態
然後
神態說
雖然都是CX
都傳銷
然後那個
是人捧出來的
並不是說我這個
就說說完
你所有一個鏈
你說那個
今天我推特上
跟人說這個事情
你說那個
他說碎
我說碎鏈
我用GPE5.5
我可能幾天
你給你升車
那可能都不用幾天
我還沒事
就可能都不用幾天
讀一下你那個代碼
然後弄一下很快的
你的所有的鏈的
技術在哪裡呢
你看公開的
你的差別在哪裡
差別在人
你這些人
人不認不認
這個傳銷的團隊
有人幫你拉人嗎
如果你的基礎是這個東西
那我覺得沒有什麼門檻
就是這個東西
沒有特別大價值
所有山賴壁
我覺得我在壁拳裏面
被他們說的最慘的是
因為我以前講
壁拳所有山賴壁拳
不要歸零
那我仍然相信
所有的山賴壁拳
都歸零
一分價值不值
這個很像喔
我記得
我被罵死了
說這個事情
我說這個是因為罵死
最早講的人
我說所有山賴壁
一分錢不值
就是我一個部分買
比特幣為什麼可以買
比特幣有很大的原因
因為
第一呢
它確實就是
它不太能改了
所以你也不能鎖我帳號
你用USDT
你能夠鎖我帳號
你在比特幣和以太坊上
都不太能鎖我帳號
以太坊的認可度
沒那麼高
所以我知道的
所有的犯罪分子的
錢權比特幣
然後犯罪分子
你不要小看
這部分錢
一年就兩三千億
也不值
我那個時候
跟我說這個話的人
是個情報公司的
我不說名字
是一個以色列情報公司的外包商
它是幫以色列情報公司
收集到
Ossos收集
Posa的數據情報
它在暗網收集
所有數據情報
它個人買了
無數的比特幣
2016年17年
他們買的
它是這麼一個人
當時我們是去以色列
跟他聊的
然後它的態度是這樣
那個時候說
兩千億到三千億
暗網交易
全是比特幣
現在可能有一部分
轉到USDT
因為USDT安全的
會轉到USDT
不安全的還是比特幣
所以你這部分
有沒有這個需求
肯定有的
所以你說比特幣
能不能被直接替代掉
不可能
那不及銀行賬戶
他們的錢
要儘管養賬
所以這個是
我覺得Bitcoin是有價值的
對 有價值
不代表
是業務是上檯面的光線
就是你拔開它的外移
看到它那裏面
它是這樣的
那你說
比方說你是
一個清算節點
或者是像索羅納
或者像Bn鏈
那有23個
清算節點
終於第大半
就一半以上
掌握在Bn手上
那你說這樣的東西
它在這個
那這些人
能放心把這東西
放在BnB上嗎
不會的
所以其他的生產幣
對我來講
沒有什麽價值
是的
我記得當年
印象很深刻
就是2024年
你就發一篇文說
有幾個山寨幣
一帳萊莫棋
就是水
T
然後Gamble
然後
然後要長期做空
然後後來
好像那個烹飪
對
很多人在噴
但其實後來
也證實了
這些山寨
是真的一直在疊
然後疊到看不見底
這樣子
但你後來
你也有提到說
我記得當年
也是
你一開始
就是不太看得好Solana
然後
但是在
我記得是在
2024年中的時候
然後你就說到
你看懂Solana的邏輯
然後你當時開始
轉多Solana
那麽
然後你也有提到說
像是
Solana
像是EMB
OKX
這些交易所必
然後其實
跟其他的生產幣
是不同的邏輯
那麽這些是
自身的
那麽你現在
就是
現在來到2026
說過
我不是這麽做嗎
我說他們是
有裝
會去拉盤
然後
他是個獨廠
那他獨廠
做得好不好
你覺得他獨廠
能不能做好
對吧
但是他本質上
沒有
就是你得
你得跟別人
有點競爭
差別優勢
就是你跟
人家有什麽difference
因為不一樣
你完全是練了
一點difference
那就是
很多人這裡
搞半導體過來聽我
然後我就說一下
幣權的生態是怎麽樣的
這個
這個沒關係
我就是
我說大交易所
這個不是說
幣安不好
就是
大交易所都一樣的
就是你要上幣
你要把你流通牌的
15%交給交易所
每家都差不多
所以你其實
他們做的事情
就是一起
發一個token以後的過程
就是我
而且他大部分
其他幣都是鎖住的
你活幣裏面
就是三之一
在交易所手上
所以其實
最近以來的生態是
你要去上幣裝
相不方
他也拉不動幣
就是你每一個上幣
我們的合定標準
就是能割多少
割
你就把這個詞
什麽意思
你有一個確定的數字
你在debt上面
能割多少
你在
上了哪個交易所
能割多少
你上了prep
上了spot
能割多少
然後
因為
壟斷性太強了
所以有一些
就相當於澳門獨場
它是獨場
獨場
它壟斷性太強
所以有人去開街邊檔
所有鏈上的交易所
都是街邊檔
獨場
你舉個例子
我們現在也去
Hyperliquist上去交易
Hyperliquist交易要玩900毫秒
它拿著你的訂單
看到了
然後市場動了
它就不給你成交
市場動了不好
對你應非
對你不好
它就給你成交
然後要給你成交的時候
它就去必安那邊Hatch一下
它所有的東西
都是必安來的
你看所有這些
所謂的鏈上交易所
包括
我就不點名
都一樣
都差不多
所以你說
區塊鏈
整個這個行業裏
沒有哪個talker
或哪個生態
我反正不太買的
我除了video都買的
是的
謝謝
程度上
你是Bitcoin Maxi
Herman哥
就是說這種
堅定只持有Bitcoin
然後
一路看多到
一路看多的這種瘋子
不是
我是Bitcoin Allocator
就是我
我大部分是
我是Sami Maxi
對
Sami Maxi
這一句
一點
那麼Bitcoin這部分
也想要問Herman哥
就是對於MicroStraighterZ
現在他們怎麼看
就是
你是想提到說
他們
其實他們今年
是可以一直狗著的
然後他們可以
MNAPD於V1的話
他們就賣VDC
相反就賣股票
然後我們接下來看到
IDOLogy他們STRC
融錢
融得很不錯
然後他們
但是他們現在沒有在無腦的
就不斷地去賣VDC
反而現在
最近開始放出一些風聲
來測試就是
賣VDC的這個風向
那麼你對於他們
就是接下來
他們會怎麼樣
就是有點像是
主動做裝的感覺
就是
去對這個市場產生影響
然後他們
接下來半年到一年的時間
他們
會怎麼樣在影響VDC的後續
我這樣說
是我對VDC市場的理解
Crypto市場理解是這樣子的
因為你們可能不太一樣
MicroStrategy在裡面
只是一個Player
它並不是一個Dominator Player
它也不是一個價格決定者
然後Crypto市場
是一個
我會不得罪人
Crypto市場是一個
非常Manipulated Market
所以呢
因為你在股票市場上
你不太能夠做
很多事情在Crypto市場
都可以做
然後 being said
我沒有說
Trump or whoever
Manipulated Information
這些都是小頭
我說的是他
Day by day
Hour by hour
Minutes by minutes
都在Be Manipulated
In one way or another
它有流動性
多流動性少
本身對它的影響
很大
這個是方向性的影響
但是有人在短劇拉盤
中劇拉盤
長劇拉盤
而且
因為小盤是
全是
小盤沒人敢拉的
全都是裝了
所以基本上
這些Manipulated Market
Manipulated Information
基本上都集中
在那幾個大的上
所以 Michael Strategy
它有兩個參數可以看
一個是它的靜止坦
就是Nav多少
然後第二個
就是 Michael Strategy
就是開那個Beta
Market Beta
所以當你回去
看Market Beta的時候
你要知道
這個市場是怎麼樣的
就是它最終是
必須求的
然後最終它確實
可以對沖一些流動性的
但是它在中間
是一直在為各種各樣操控
所以你不能
去做任何短線的Trade
是的
你如果是要買Bitcoin
那我覺得你要你的Holding
是至少是以年為單位的
不然就不要去Hold
你不如去買點3米
我隨便給你兩張票
都比Bitcoin表現好
嗯 理解理解
OK
好 那麼在Bitcoin這邊
想要再問一下Herman
就是對於
但是穩定比現在的一些看法
那麼像是Circle這種股票
那麼
以前有提到說
如果是賭Bitcoin的流量的話
是賭Coin Base
那麼賭BTC的時候
買Michael Strategy
那麼這樣洗的話
會降低Circle的利潤
所以是不太看好的
你實在對於
穩定比的看法
有沒有什麼改變
還是一樣維持一段
我身邊好多人炒穩定比
就是那些放的
好多好多放炒穩定比
就是前一段時間
你都在買Circle
然後我沒有參與
我沒有參與
不是Bitcoin
就是這個放
就是因為我Bitcoin
焦慮到很大
所以我基本上在Bitcoin
的情況他們會問我
所以身邊問到
我Circle的人非常非常多
然後
我覺得這個有一個割裂
就好像在半導體行業
和非半導體行業
有個巨大的割裂
一樣的一種割裂
就是半導體行業裏面
做AI的行業裏面
人覺得我Token需求無限大
然後半導體行業裏面
說我看這東西缺貨
缺到30年
你擔心什麼呢
然後在外面
站在外面
說AI是個泡沫
或者半導體
啪啪啪啪
長成這樣子
這個是很割裂的
然後同時的話
但你不能說
是市場交易錯了
還是行業knowledge錯的
有可能是行業knowledge錯
往往行業knowledge錯
那我這裏只能給你提供
行業knowledge
因為我不炒Circle這個幣
然後我確實知道
很多inflow的money
很多錢進去買的
Circle這個公司
它的本質上
是一個不負利息的
Money Market Fund
它有50%的錢
是要給到coin base
然後這個代表是什麼
就是包括到現在為止
所有的穩定幣支付場景
靠的都是交易所
那必安跟交易所的term
是必安拿走99%
這個是for certain
我告訴你
我知道是誰
然後怎麼做
USD1沒有拿
那是for another reason
來這個我們就不說了
我們USD1沒有拿
但是除了USD1
你必安以前說的
所有的穩定幣
是需要99%的利潤
永遠歸必安
包括不在必安上交易的
都要歸必安
這個是一個基礎
那為什麼還有人願意做
因為你拿到一張牌照
一點用都沒有
新加坡也有牌
新加坡好多
我定比它還沒有用的
你不可能有流量
Circle有的流量
是原來是空一來的
但是它現在沉澱了很多
大家的相信
對它東西的相信
它的價值來自於兩部分
第一部分來自於
Money Market Fund的收益
它不給投資人
也就是它做了一個政策套利
這個政策套利是
你一旦這個Token付了利息
它就變成Securities
然後這邊證券
VSEC管
所以我今天不付利息
那我就不是Securities的利息
被我拿走了
這個是收口的核心價值
政策套利
第二部分
還是政策套利
我現在拿張牌照乾這個事情
那別人沒有牌照
所以呢我很有
又是政策套利
你願意把一個Long term
投資的錢
壓到一個因為政策套利
還獲得盈利的一公司
那麽我肯定是不敢
然後第三
收口這個公司
跟政治掛鉤是很深的
你看看它股東名單
如果你相信
Lutnik在這個團隊裏面
一直很長期的話
你可以去買收口
其實Lutnik他們
他們其實
他們自己有搞一個
Boutique的一個IB
好像是賺
最近幾年是賺撥滿盆盆
可是也得罪了不少人
他不是
這位老大哥
Trust鏈裏面
就Trump老大哥
最可信的人
他當然是個
Trust的人
對吧
但是他肯定不是最可信的那個
最可信肯定是
Securities Boutique
對吧
然後
當然大家都很可以
你老點我老點
都無所謂
都老點
這個東西
就是
怎麼說呢
就是這三個原因
我幫我講這三個原因
這是他的compatible
就是他的競爭優勢
你說這麼一個競爭優勢的公司
我去買它
我還不能去買台積電
對 沒錯
這個台積電
就是
上禮拜五的時候
台積電是跌
那那一天
剛好上禮拜四
發一個新聞出來說
因為川普
在喊Intel
Intel拿了蘋果的訂單
這個實際上
就是說
Herman哥你也是
之前很早
基本上應該是
全網最早在喊
說要買Intel的人
可不可以跟我們
去年的時候
就是說三十五倍
現在其實也基本大不了
是
所以可不可以跟我們
分析一下
當時的思路是什麼
還有你現在怎麼看Intel
他到底
整體他的大命運怎麼走
當時是看估值
就是說
他投了這麼多晶圓廠
當時
因為我們在
中國有晶圓廠
DUV的晶圓廠
一場片沒出
它的PB都是1
然後
那個Intel的EUV
那個時候
我們是內部知道
它可能是70左右的兩率
60幾幾是兩率
然後
那個時候
60幾70兩率
它的PB是-1
我覺得這是更fair的
這是個不公平的一個trade
所以不管
是不是創不上臺
或怎麼樣
結果都是一樣的
就是Intel只有兩條路
一條是破產
這件事情不會發生
第二條路
它只會被拆掉
它不會破產
拆掉也值錢
然後
第二條路
就是它18億
這麼好走出來不死
不死
它就應該到四五千億
所以當時
我是這麼看的
也是這麼買的
那大的倉位
是在去年
就是
Trump說要
Trump把成立物弄下臺
之後
差不多這個時候定權
然後
那個時候
我是明確知道蘋果
要投資它的
然後我明確知道
蘋果在上面留言
然後
這個是行業信息
這個市場不知道
我知道
這是
明確的
你可以看我推特
我早就說了這個事情
了解
那對於現在的局勢
你怎麼看
因為看起來
現在消費太多了
就是現在
櫻桃上面消費的東西
太多了
那麼說
那個後面還有什麼
就是蘋果
會給它投資
或者是給它
聯發費用
把台積電聯發費用
分一部分給它
然後這可能還沒出來
但其他基本上
能消費的東西都消費了
然後接著的話
它就要
實現它的消費了
那實驗消費
櫻桃肯定會
肯定會拉的
就是它
沒有
櫻桃肯定會拉的
所以櫻桃肯定會拉的
這個新的東西
然後讓人開發
這咖咖過程中間發生問題
和你跟櫻桃團隊的對接
然後櫻桃也不是
很那個
因為原來它主要是對內的
然後它要對外
再去談這些東西的時候
它就肯定會冒出
各種各樣的問題
這是必然
所以它是在短期消費完以後
它後面要去
fulfill它的這些問題
就是打開這種填滿
但是我覺得櫻桃有四個
至少有四個台階
如果不是五個的話
至少有四個台階要做
它第一個台階是不破產
第二個台階是說
它的金圓廠是能夠用的
能給內部用
至少能給內部用
第三個台階是金圓廠
能給外面人用
第四個是說金圓廠能夠盈利
然後第五台階
我能夠實質性的
對台積電形成替代
不是我完全替代
我能夠實質性的
對台積電形成一部分的挑戰
但是我能分開一點市場份
那這五個台階
這五個台階全部會完成
這個事情你肯定能夠捨得
就是台灣再強
我知道台灣人都很看不清它
但是台灣再強
再怎麼樣
你在拜腦體的行業裡面
一旦發生大缺貨
獲利的一定是落後的人
就好像我們看到光模塊大缺貨
獲利的是AOL一樣道理
現在金圓大缺貨
包括封裝大缺貨
獲利的就是銀行
因為原來你的PTK
是絕對沒有人會用
也不是說
川普幫你去做Marketing
誰幫你做Marketing都沒用
誰願意去花錢
去試你這個東西
來花錢的
花了錢以後
我還得去台積電那裏解釋
為什麼要幹這個東西
然後台積電給我減一點份額
現在不會
現在是
我知道產能
無論如何都不夠
我花點錢
這點錢
蘋果給它300億
蘋果最多給它300億
300億對蘋果來說是什麼錢
無所謂的
然後不是個事情
然後給了這個資源和錢之後
能夠可能帶來的產能
的效應會大很多
所以它是這個追趕者
它真正獲利是從哪裡獲利
它是從半導體大缺貨
或者是從台積電
在前一段時間
比較保守的投入
中間真正獲利
這個是經濟利益
並不是Trump
或者是帶動神
所以你現在
回頭看它的估值
它估值先兩倍多PB吧
現在120塊錢
120塊錢
就兩倍多PB吧
兩倍多PB
因為它要把CPU那塊給擊掉
然後再加上那個
那個晶圓廠
那個是兩倍PB
這麼算
但你看現在
Globo防水是兩倍多PB
Globo最近長了
還不止兩倍了
三四倍了吧
台積電要
台積電正常時候
我們認為是七倍
那現在可能是十倍
對吧
然後
你就算跟Globo比
Globo是28nm
至少英草是全世界唯一
兩個
能夠做出
兩nm芯片的
三星不算
三星是個屎
三星證明自己
只能做30%
30%兩率了
它這個確實不行
那你要真的
從後面開發出來
三星不行
有可能是跟擴放有關
這個
因為你看你
誰在上面是吧
然後
這個可能跟擴放有關
它以後也可能也會提高
這個我們先拋開不說
但是
真正現在
18a的兩率能夠用的
就是18a這兩nm
那個兩率能用的
只有英草
和台積電
就是兩降
那你給它
兩倍PB
我覺得是可以給的
就現在這個價錢是可以給的
但是
中間會從兩倍到零倍
零倍到三倍
三倍到五倍
然後再回到兩倍
然後來來回回
但是你知道
三年以後
它肯定會到六七倍
因為這個是兩率
是個單邊漢數
你有兩率是什麼東西
是一個
我不斷精進
我的記憶調
是我的
你來調我記憶
把我記憶調好
第二個是客戶
在上面開發
這個是雙向一起合作出來的
就是說
這個過程
就是說他一定跑出來
客戶也願意給你
燒錢 燒時間
給你一起搞出來
對
然後其實
我覺得
也是跟文化有關
我講難聽一點
我們台灣人就是
夠奴性
然後身夠好
對不對
在這個小島上面
那老實講
我們的優勢是什麼
就只剩半導體
我認為
你們優勢是乾
你們優勢乾比較好
健保也不錯
健保體系不錯
不過
但是你要想一個問題
是英套證明
它兩率能提高的
三星證明自己兩率提高不了
是
對吧
18A證明自己兩率能提高
所以現在比方說
18A對那是80級
85啊
80級
它對外我不知道
這個是個魔幻的數字
什麼流過
那對外的話
那個成立5可能覺得是65
它下面可能覺得是60
那 whatever
whatever一個數字
但是它這個兩率往上攀
是一個
大干率的事件
基本上
你可以把兩率攀升
就這邊
一個月1到2%
這個是1到2點
這個就是
就是這個數字
它差一點就是1
它不乾
你乾你兩個點一塊
它不乾它一個點
但是你往後
往後看
它的結果是什麼
它結果還是
你拿到一個估值
就是舉個例子
現在今天如果
英特爾手上
沒有兩奈米晶圓廠
它只有3奈米和5奈米晶圓廠
那3奈米5奈米
台積電是非常非常成熟
對不對
我不需要最新
最新晶圓廠
3奈米5奈米
那我的晶圓廠
兩率如果在90以上
那我值不值錢
我肯定是值錢的
我應該
我哪怕拿不到
你現在台積電10倍PB
那我拿5位PB可以吧
所以我說
它並不是說取代台積電
而是說
PB
或者是它能夠
挑戰台積電
或者是PB台積電
一部分東西
那這個已經達到
它第四個階段
那你現在看
那樣的話就一萬億以上
甚至還不止
你算一算吧
它現在是一千億的
一千零
八十億好像
一千零八十億的Book
Book Value
那你每年投一百五十億
後面可能
加大投入一百五十億
兩百億
你過了三年
你這個Book就變很大了
然後再把這個Book
去成一個六倍PB
七倍PB
那這個公司
三年以後
它在這就是
我們看三年的市值
再加上它CPU
CPU我們還不算它缺貨
CPU後面缺死掉
就CPU我們看到
你知道華強北的CPU
已經漲了三倍到五倍了
還在漲
沒有停過
你知道華強北吧
你這個你知道對吧
全世界那個半導體中心
就是零片件集散中心
華強北的CPU
它拆下那個服務器的CPU
現在已經漲了三倍到五倍了
所以我們還沒算
它有可能在CPU上
可以能獲利
它這個估值
就是說
就這麼算
它總是能走上去
但是中間肯定很波折
100%
各種各樣問題
它不出問題才怪的
不
我先稍微把
那個TSMC這部分
再探討一下
就是說
TSMC
那他既然可以搞先進封裝
或者你說
兩代比三代比
COWOS
這個
Chift on
這個叫做
就COWOS
這個最先進封裝技術
那
COWOS
那它到底為什麼
它的
這個本益比
PE那麼低
才20倍
21.3
這
不不不
晶圓廠就是用PB來估值
它不是用PE來估值
這個就是為什麼
我
待會如果你要我去講一下存儲
我可以再講上存儲問題
存儲我沒有去買存儲
我就是沒有買過存儲
我確實沒有存儲這個狀
但是
我就覺得存儲應該是用PS去估值
因為那是個周期性行業
你晶圓廠
因為我投入了很多
我就是應該用PB來估值
就好像我舉個例子
我是個房地產租賃行業
對
這個比喻很
就是非常切實的
就是晶圓廠
其實是一個房地產租賃行業
台積電最賺錢的晶圓
它並不是EUB
它是DUB
而且是老縣村DUB
因為那些東西找折就折完了
一分錢都不值
但是現在每年
還給我產生大量的晶圓
這是台積電廠
寄來賺的錢是最多的這個
但是
因為台積電是外部代工
所以各種各樣的需求都到它那裡來
然後它能夠保持這些
所有的這個晶圓廠
回過來說
英超
英超它只有自己內部現成
所以它只需要
它當時CPU用的那個現成
按老的東西是賣掉的
它老晶圓廠也是賣掉的
然後它也沒有需求
當時也沒有需求去做EUB
然後沒有需求做EUB的話
那它就沒有辦法去投入那個
7nm 5nm 3nm
它沒法投入
那台積電有蘋果的需求吧
它沒有蘋果需求
它投入不了
投入不了它去做
比方說
它要做先進的
它就把7nm去
把14nm去多次報廣搞7nm
那個成本就很高
時間就很長
所以它幹不過AMD
它不是晶片設計不行
它是那個晶圓廠不行
可是台積電的DUB
我若理解沒錯的話
DUB它的
因為DUB是EUB的上一代吧
它也最多只能幹
5到7nm而已
不,DUB幹是14nm以上
OK
對,EUB幹是7nm以下
就中國為什麼幹不過台灣
你知道嗎
中國很強啊,半導體
就我這裡在說
中國半導體很強
又有人噴詞
但是我明確告訴你
中國半導體非常非常強
包括中國在新興空裝上很厲害
武漢那個實驗室的中興興空裝
絕對不比台積電差
但是問題是
它是後導風裝嗎
你卡都沒有你風裝個屁啊
就是你為什麼沒有卡呢
因為你沒有EUB
所以中國半導體被老大哥
不是老大哥
老大哥是很秘密的
我剛才敢講他
就是被老大哥身邊那個
任真飛這個鳥人
帶掉了一條鞋路上去
任真飛說的是
我們中國一定是需要有
任何東西都要有
國產替代
那我要去替代什麼
我要去替代CPU和GPU
CPU和GPU用的是先進風裝
用的是EUB
就先進製程
用的是EUB的製程
用EUB製程
那我手上沒有EUB機器
怎麼辦的
那我就讓
中國機器去配合我
怎麼配合
把我14大米的東西
去搞多次包裹
我多次包裹
我成本乘以二
時間乘以二
良率除以二
良率壞的乘以二
就良率變一半
那我這個東西
就沒有任何商業價值
但是沒有商業價值
沒有關係
因為我華為
我愛國生意
我被封鎖了
所以中國必須用我的
我把成本提到很高
我就愛國生意
你們都通通不能用台積平卡
中國人
其他的公司以前小米
這些都沒有被封鎖
就是我
華為被封鎖了
我愛國我用中國
所以你們通通不能用
把你們通通封死
這就是華為幹的事情
就是這個腳使棍
就在中國
整個半導體行列
最大腳使棍就華為
但是
所以
對
但是它不是差
它是
它是像被三體人
這個可能
中國一本小說
你沒看過
就是外星人
把你的科技給封鎖了
不讓你到這個
Level上上不去了
這就是Glassylin
這Glassylin就是EUV的機器
所以我們今天回過來看
中國在
應該走哪條路
中國應該幹存儲
它現在的戰略
就回頭幹存儲了
OK
這個幹存儲
這個人在中國
就是那個
發家部主任叫
鄭山傑
原來是安徽省委書記
然後省委書記還是什麼生長
然後他在那個中
長薪最對慘的時候
給他一百二十億貸款
就把長薪給救活了
因為存儲DUV就能幹
現在中
而且存儲的東西是Commology
就是你長薪生產的存儲
這DDR
和你那個
三星海地之生產的
和美光生產
沒有任何區別
這東西一樣的
都是一個標準
所以我在DDR上
我可以無限的給你搞偷產
他們現在就搞這個事情
但現在問題
中國可能買不到
這麼多光刻機
買不到這麼的DUV的機器
因為
當你要買DUV機器
去年要買DUV是很容易的
然後因為
今年要買DUV
全都在買
因為存儲不夠了
全世界都在買DUV
你現在DUV也買不到
那
中國能夠集全國之力
就是說你一個晶圓廠
你比方說當時
中國鋪了很多來去發到DUV晶圓廠
你鋪了那些晶圓廠
如果你在留其他片
比方車歸心片
我要給你哭的
我那個
國家的那個發蓋
我也給你哭的
告訴你能留多少片的
我現在哭他都不給你
你必須要幫我去配合長青
你必須要把你的晶圓廠
去過去留那個DDR去
這條路走的是對的
所以其實
我
Sorry
所以其實當時
大陸應該是說
我要盡
我要盡力去拿到DUV
而不是說用DUV
搞多次的曝光
不是
不要搞厲害的我的國
不要去天天想去打台灣
那你家DUV
本來就給你的
你天天想去打台灣
你家為什麼會把DUV
給你
就看那些無聊的事情
OK明白
不過我這裡政治就
不說我
到時候把我在香港
把我抓起來
對
但是你本質原因是這個
中國的所有的半導體
中國所有的半導體公司
你可以看
它全是台灣人頭
全是台積電頭
最早福祉的全是台灣人頭
就是說
說穿了你的耕
和你的那個
最早的這個能力
來自於全是台灣
包括你像看中威
包括這些公司
最早成立五那個時候在那個華燈
華燈母打機頭
多給頭了
都是他們頭的
我有大哥就是
接了華燈的那個
所有的S基金
就我們在半導體的
很多知識都那個大哥來的
他就是接了那個
成立五的華燈的那個S基金
然後最後賺了好多少錢
但是這本質上這些
本來的資源和錢
都是台灣
包括你看三星哈利
是在那個山東的那個廠
就大連那個廠
那廠原來英特爾的
人家以前
什麼東西都沒有封鎖你
是你自己做出來了嗎
你天天搞厲害的我的國
天天要去
搞些有的沒的事情
那人家
人家不封鎖你才怪了對吧
明白
那是你說
那是你說說回來這個存儲
就是說
你剛剛說
其實大陸應該是要搞存儲
這個比較像
commodity的聲音
這個可以再跟我們
更深入聊一下
因為EUV去生產
先進一市城
比如說要去留那個
華為的手機芯片
這件事情是吃力不討好的
就是我本來能夠留
一萬片
現在只能留五千片
因為我需要多次曝光
就要多次的時間
然後因為多次曝光
你的良率就是N次方
你一個現成一次走完了
N次方就是你
你把課完去服侍
然後搞過來
它這個流程
七八個到流程
然後回來回來回來搞
所以它是N次方
所以你的良率有變低
本來那個良率比方說是
七十七七七四十九
你變五十了對吧
所以你良率
距離你的那個時間長
你佔用的EUV的機器多
然後產能低價錢高
這個是不經濟的
就是這個本質是不經濟的
那現在有一個變化在中國
就是我覺得
在變化中國
就是朱一鳴在國內
因為他畢竟是
一個已經一年賺七百億
今年預期要賺七百億的
半導體公司
在中國歷史上
沒有發生過
包括華為就做不到
他是一年賺七百億的半導體
他的內部的聲音很響
他的sponsor是那個
鄭山傑是他各位主任
鄭山傑是很想上
這政治了
他很想上那個
國務院當副總理
所以他是決心要去幫
鄭山傑幫助一名
等於是要幫長興
幫長興的就是
我們要把
我們在半導體上面的這個戰略
從國產替代CPU和GPU
換到國產替代存儲
換到我們用存儲
把世界市場給基子
這個戰略目標再變化
它能夠動用的力量
是整個國家的
國家意志力量
就是他們做事情
你不看經濟利益的
不是說我現在
比方說
低利亞生產多少
然後我要保持多少的馬距
沒有這一說
我是虧錢也可以
你知道國內的
現在競元廠
一個競元廠
一個省的一個競元廠
DUE
一個廠子買了幾台機器
銀行可以帶1000億給你
零利息
哇那麼愛國
不需要
對
他們不差錢了
他們對錢感覺都沒有的
這就是長興
你這個競元廠
他無利息
零利息給你帶給你
然後長興去拍1000個人團隊
到你那邊住點
然後把你那邊調通
然後你去產片
你不同意
你原來比方山傑
產車衛星片
不讓你產
你本來一個廠
我在產車衛星片
我不讓你產
我國家發購也不批給你
現在等於是舉全國之力來搞
雜國
對對對
舉全國之力來搞這個事情
對
所以你現在
他預期想擴廠的規模
非常非常大
回到說那個
他擴廠規模
沒那麼快擴出來
他這機器買不了
買不了
後面所有的材料全缺的
他們想這麼搞
但是這麼搞
至少是條生路
搞出來的所有的產能
都是賺錢的
你想中興幹出來
長興幹出來不賺錢了
長興幹出來也賺錢
長興和長存
就符合了我前面講這個邏輯
是什麼呢
就是在拜老體真正缺貨的時候
最最獲利的是那個追趕者
長興和長存
兩代公司差點死掉去年
去年長存
長存在那個
長興在融資的時候
才400億
去年年初的時候
今年一個月賺100億
你看看那個三星海地士
你就知道了
那去年的時候
其實三星海地士
壓力沒有漲價
因為長興長存
當時出來的滴滴
還要折價個20% 30%
然後他良率還比你低
那你的所有的毛捲
就變成零了
所以你產一片虧一片
就要靠國家補貼
那今年不是
今年他良率也提高了
然後就是我的卡滴滴R
沒有區別的
所以我的那個一價
比方說三星海地士
一價在國內也沒有
完全持平了
然後我的良率也上升
因為我用了多
我良率也上升了
所以滴滴R5
自己也沒有問題
它完全可以產
以至於他今年的
營利後變得非常非常好
這就是追趕邏輯
長興的長存就是一朵
追趕邏輯
然後我用的是
DUV的機器
沒有任何問題
了解
那能不能跟我們說說
為什麼滴滴R
跟HBM來看的話
為什麼HBM才能
真的有所謂的
這個成長股的估值
但滴滴R
它就是一個
比較像commodity這樣
對
滴滴R是commodity
因為滴滴R
是每一家產出來的東西
都是一樣的
它是CPU和
舉個例子吧
我做那個
成熟就是那個
CSP端的CPU和
PC端的CPU的價錢
麻卷是不一樣的
對吧
PC端的CPU先賣都賣不掉
然後PC端的CPU的麻卷
也可能大概30左右吧
然後CSP那邊
可能有70
就數據中心那邊
那有70
那
這個是一個產品
我的CPU是AMD的CPU
還是Intel的CPU
是完全不同的
然後我的那個
那個Performance
這些東西都是不同的
所以它是有brand
它是我一個product
那當我產量消耗不好的時候
我也不會說CPU
我會說CPU今天從
也比方說250塊錢一張
一張卡
然後跌到220塊錢
然後這不存在
然後我市場好的時候
我也不可能從220塊
250塊錢給你直接長到
1000塊錢
這也是不存在
這都不存在
所以它就是一個產品
就好像我今天做的手機
我銷量好
銷量不好
銷量脫銷
或者是製銷有成熟
這是一個比較穩定的
所以它應該是能夠獲得
我們PE股市
記憶股市
就成長公司股市
但是存儲不是
存儲和CPU的本質區別
你從那個
從那個Data Center的CPU
去切到
消費短的CPU
它需要幾個月時間切
它差不多但是要切
然後DDR和那個HBM
是不需要切
就是HBM是DDR給疊起來的
簡單來說就是疊起來
所以HBM5疊起來就變
那個DDR5疊起來就變HBM
它在HBM
拉的漲價的時候
把DDR本質也漲上去了
也就是我賣的Brandon
Budder的DDR
那個Wafer出貨量
大概在75以上
然後加上我那一點點的
HBM那個35層疊起來
然後能夠賣個25%的
那個出貨量
這兩個東西加起來
Margin全部給你搞到80了
所以這件事情
是不是可以sustain的
可以持續嗎
市場就正常市場
是不會認為
這種事情是可以持續的
你CPU是能夠漲10倍
然後一直維持在上面不行吧
你不要說CPU了
GPU也不行
你以為它的卡確成這個樣子
它漲價了嗎
它沒有吧
就是台積電這麼缺
台積電漲價了嗎
沒有吧
就是正常的
你非商品性的物質
它不是這樣去定價的
HBM為什麼是
因為HBM需要有封裝
然後HBM需要有封裝
有封裝檢測
然後互相設計
還有一點不一樣
這個東西
它是有那個
跟CPU這些差不多
但是bug在於
存儲公司的
它的原材料
是跟HBM一起漲的
所以它HBM漲上去了
它把原材料一起漲上去了
所以原材料的Margin
它的 earning
它並不是主要是HBM來的
它的 earning主要是賣DDR來的
也就是DDR漲價
導致了它3%的盈利是這麼來的
4%的盈利是這麼來的
4%它還說少了
還更多
其實是這麼來的
這個Margin整體提高
那那一部分
你應該把它當成一個
游景區
賣油礦
或者是賣商品
這麼去估值
但現在大家不是這麼估的
為什麼最大時間
大家炒存儲
我存儲肯定破信考
但是我根本就不會買
肯定破信考
但是我也不會買
為什麼
因為存儲現在是那些
完全不懂半導體的人進來投資
讓不懂半導體的人進來投資的時候
第一眼看按的
它就是
你的意識多少
PE高還是PE低
因為你看所有其他東西
PE都很高
你比方說你看英特爾
你覺得PE100多倍
好貴
其實並不貴
對吧
我剛剛講的
英特爾不是這麼估值的
所以並不過
它也不會管
它也還不懂
但是它看到美光的PE很低
它就直接賣美光
Sandex P1個里
Sandex
是這麼搞的
然後這一批人
就是一些比較傳統的
只有金融背景的
那些基金經理
或者是甚至
養老金經理
或者是這些
這些錢在前兩好星期
衝了比較多進去
所以把那個市場
炒得很高
那這批錢還有嗎
還有很多
包括原來很多同事
後來沒有機會了解半導體
都覺得美光偏樣
但我覺得美光很貴
OK
所以
所以其實基本上
就是說
因為DDR
它的依價能力
沒有HBM那麼強
所以基本上DDR
它只是一個commodity
對對對
它製成也是commodity
怎麼說
芯片和芯片是不同的
我英特爾和AMD的芯片是不同的
但是三星和海利市的DDR是一樣的
DDR4就是DDR4
DDR5就是DDR5
它有一個專門的標準的
這東西一樣的
OK
明白
那我會再把場景
帶回到亞洲這邊
因為像台股跟韓股
大家這個記憶體廠
或者CPU廠
也都
超著蠻瘋的
那對於台股韓股
這邊
他們都有在看嗎
我只看在美國能交易的
比方說日月光
日月光
封測
我
我說
就是說現在
我說一下算力的提高
原來的算力提高
都是Wafer在提高
就是你三大米
三大米
Wafer在提高
然後
現在Wafer的提高
會比日月來月小
它是一個LOG韓數
然後
Packaging的提高
是一個指數韓數
以後
我們主要的算力提高
來自於Packaging
就是為什麼
像台積電
它要把Covas
作為它最合金的東西
然後要抓在手上
它分配的是這個現成
也就是說
你可以這樣理解
我的Wafer是賣白酒
我的Covas是酒瓶子
你不能夠只賣白酒吧
你必須把酒瓶自己買進去
然後採錢
我才值錢
我公司才值錢
這個很簡單
然後
現在
比如說
Google和
因為
Hyperscale
美國的大的科技公司
現在越來越注重成本了
就剛我們回到
剛剛講CAPEX的問題
因為原來
不是CAPEX模式的時候
它需要做到CAPEX
它手很鬆
它花多少錢都無所謂
那Google以前是最標準的這個
它給亞瓦哥
每天賺了好多錢
然後
現在Google開始
越來越
精打細算
扣門了
其實每家都一樣
因為你一旦進入一個CAPEX模式
就是我的CAPEX效率
CAPEX效率就是成本控制
這個就跟生產業是一樣
那我Google
做芯片
做卡拉說也是這樣
它現在最希望我
直接把訂單
像蘋果一樣下到TSMC
就用TSMC不接
那個
然後Google還提出
一個比較過分的要求
就比方說最近
炒得比較兇的
就是讓英塔幫他做封裝了
然後英塔幫他做Five Packaging
那其實就是
要通過MTK
Militech
中文叫什麼
叫做聯發科是吧
就要通過Militech
去下單
到TSMC
去下那個Wafer
然後把這個Wafer
給英特爾去做封裝
就是我拿了台積電酒
裝英塔的瓶子
這個事情
我其實覺得行不大通
走不出量的
台積電不會給你留這麼多
到時候
封配線程的一堆問題
各種各樣的問題
你看著嘛
現在當然市場
現在在炒這個東西
炒我就不去頂著它去說
但是你得知道這個東西的本質
所以
封裝類型的這些東西
都是
才是市場會很缺的
你要看台股比方說
日月光
日月光就是靠著台積電的
然後台積電
一條線調通了
對面日月光
直接對面看
因為
封裝是要很多手動的
它不是完全自動的處理的
所以
它確實擴產的
會擴的很慢
真的是手作
然後
那麼在封裝裡面
日月光
背靠台積電
那肯定沒有問題
OK
所以基本上
反而是
整個問題產業中
上中下游
是封裝這一塊
才會
可能有潛在最多的
upside potential
我覺得這樣
就是你看整個token
我們說
就是整個token產出
我們每年token需求
增加好幾倍
然後我們整個token產出
是誰在提高算理產出token
那token產出最大的大頭
是anthropic open AI
那毫無疑問
然後anthropic open AI
下來
就是
Racketon的封裝
GPU
CPU
然後
光模塊的對接
然後存儲
這些東西
中間
我覺得封裝
要這樣一半吧
就是封裝
副兩個層面
第一個是covers的封裝
就是把那個
那個芯片層面封裝
還有Racketon的鞋頭
我們不叫它封裝
它是Racketon的鞋頭
林偉達在Racketon的鞋頭
提高的這個算力也很大
所以英偉達是一個
非常非常牛的公司
非常非常牛
現在
大家因為市值太高
不去吵它
但是其實
其實它提供的算力提高
你說的這個Racketon
是說
像是computed blade
它這種
新的
ok 它這種
它把那個
啊啊啊啊啊
然後包含說它
最新一代的
沒事沒事
然後包含說它
它像它最新一代的
這個鞋片
也都是
好像是說對於這些
歐電廠
像是鴻海微創
是比較友善
因為它本身
它不需要再
重新去打磨
對
也不曉得
人家跟它一起
是像你
你從Racketon
那個
就是MV72的組裝
ODM幫它去組裝
這個跟它一起打磨
你記得當時夜冷
出問題
什麼東西出問題
它每一個採購的坑
你要跟其他人再做一次
都要重新採一次
所以現在英偉達
我覺得它的優勢是
已經建立了
整一套的互稱盒
從ODM的互稱盒
到它採購的互稱盒
你HBM這麼缺不
就是被Jason給買光了嗎
那個
它從採購
包括光波塊
產能全給買掉
有點像當年蘋果吧
你要新的那個手機廠
要能夠做出來
其實是要整個
配件的所有的產能
能夠
能夠不要那麼共不應求
然後其他人才能做出來
但是
但是問題不是
所有東西都很缺
所以我覺得
在這個
整個把這些東西
結合在整合層面
英偉達的
提高的效率是很多的
但只是產能不夠
它並不是只做GPU的
它是GPU
把它做成一個
做成一個機櫃的
然後這個機櫃裡面
要去
也有
這個機櫃
要採購貨
然後要ODM怎麼辦
這中間都是門檻
OK
明白明白
那
這個
我們時間差不多
這個最後
Herman哥有沒有
一些想跟觀眾提點一下
或者說有沒有一些
其他
Sammi的一些insight
想要再跟大家多聊聊的
我差不多都沒什麼了
我其實
說幾個吧
我覺得那個
就
我覺得大部分說的
都差不多說完了
看看你們有什麼
其他問題吧
好
還是我們現在
開放大家在
這個
開放大家舉手
來訪問一下
然後我們選人上來
如何
有人
大家有沒有一些
Sammi的
一些問題想問
Herman
我這邊看到有一位
舉手
是叫Pable
還有伯伯
比較酷
來啊來啊來聊一下
問一下
好
好歡迎伯伯
有沒有什麼問題
想要問嗎
沒有沒有他只是
他只是舉手而已
他是我好朋友
OK
看一下
還有其他兩位
我們批准了一些人
你跟他說話
伯伯要上來嗎
把他上來吧
他上來
上來吧
好
都批准了
你先說兩句
我去弄一杯水
你等我一下想
你倒好處副一下
等一下我說真的有問題
剛才只是不小心下麥了
有現在沒有問題
我可以提問嗎
歡迎歡迎
那我問一下Herman
你剛才說到
各個公司固執的方法嗎
你說英特爾要用PB
然後什麼傳出要用PS
你解釋了DDR的
商品型
那你怎麼看那樣的呢
就是你決定的
跟DDR是同一個東西嗎
好
我們稍等一下
Herman哥
Herman哥應該繼續裝水
喝杯水
大家先喝杯水
上個廁所
拿杯水
Herman哥
有聽到伯伯剛剛的問題嗎
沒有
兄弟你說什麼
問題是
你剛才解釋了
就是不同公司固執的方法吧
你說英特爾不能用PE
半導體基本上
不能用PE來固執
然後你也解釋了
DDR為什麼是一個商品
這個我是聽懂了
但是
我覺得還是有許多人
在買那個NAND
就是存儲的那個SSD這一塊
所以你怎麼看那個NAND
你的這個觀點是否
可以完全使用在NAND的公司
我覺得NAND也是個商品
然後
但是呢
現在市場
但是現在市場的機會是這樣子
就是
並不是
我們這樣的聰明人
能夠賺到所有的錢
其實有可能就是
傻人
或者是瞭解傻人的聰明人
能夠賺到最多的錢
就比方說你
對吧
你就是瞭解傻人的聰明人
你也知道這個NAND
是按照應該要商品固執的
但是
別笑
但是問題是
你去買了那個SSD
就是你認為
雖然
它不應該是用PE去固執
但是
市場上那些基金經理
就是會在3米狂熱的時候
它不看固執
直接把它當3米固執
把它當用PE固執
然後給它買到10倍PE
我覺得這可能很大
包括在MU上
都會發生這種事情
就
如果要本質來說
NAND和這個DDR都是
我覺得都是應該是
都是應該是商品固執的
就是至少是應該PS固執
如果不是
因為我覺得存儲以前
一直是用PS固執
或者你用PE固執
都可以用PS固執
因為它不一定都是產能的
它那個
它的有的產能是其他的人做的
所以
你可以把它用PE
比方說用PS固執
但是現在市場
Apparently並不是這樣
這樣在看的
就是
當一個
我就說
一個Pansion房的
它進來買的時候
它是先掃一眼不論不
看到這些PE都很高
然後先去做空檔
然後發覺自己被拉爆了
不是Pansion房
別人說完全不了解
Pansion房出來的manager管在基金
然後它是先做空檔
然後被拉爆
拉爆說我靠
Sami這麼瘋狂
我必須要買領回來
然後怎麼辦呢
看看我靠
那個
這邊有個美國六倍PE
六倍PE買它
我覺得好多好多錢
就是這個邏輯
我身邊有好多錢
都是這個邏輯
然後我現在被
很多這樣的邏輯的人
在
Flood with these kind of people
太多太多了
所以我覺得很有可能
就是
市場是永遠沒有錯的
所以當市場這樣去做的時候
他就是這樣走
然後為什麼他們願意去
支持我跟他講
我說我剛剛講這些東西
你不應該用周期估值
那些東西
但他們為什麼不在乎呢
因為在明年是不會被爭尾的
他放的也就看一年收益
他明年不會被爭尾
後年也不會被爭尾
我為什麼要去關心
一個大後年要暴跌的事情
跟我有什麼關係
所以
所以你這種才能賺大錢
對吧
如果你從這個角度來講
那確實算是最好的
我確實是有點疑惑
就是說
為什麼是要用PV
不是看PE
為什麼不看PE
因為你是個商品嘛
就是正常
以前都沒有人用PE
不值得了
你說我是一個煉油廠
不是煉油廠
我是個生產石油的公司
我沙特阿美
我能夠按PE估值嗎
那油價明天漲了300塊錢了
那我能按PE估值嗎
油價明天跌到30塊錢了
我要麼就按我的Reserve來估值
因為我不能夠確定
這個長期油價是多少
所以我不可能
用這個油價來估值
我實際上是我投入
比方說晶圓廠
一直讓我投入來估值
或者是
你的麻將一直在變
你想我們過去
那個內存的麻將變了多少
現在變80多了
以前30幾
所以它Fracture的後果很大
那前兩年剛剛又發生過
今天不是第一次
發生麻將變80的事情
比特幣挖礦那陣不也搞過一次嗎
麻將80幾
那個礦金
整個那個時候
好像也是DBM買不到
也一樣的
歷史上不是一次了
所以導致了
大家一直不會給它這個皮骨質
哪怕在過去這個牛市的時候
也沒有給
但是這次確實給
這次確實給的原因就是
它的缺貨周期會更長
可見的
確定性的缺貨周期更長
那如果說
我們認為我們賺的是誰的錢
我們賺的是行業的錢
那我賺的是行業錢
我肯定不滿
我寧可去買光
我光也不一定會長得比你少
你有可能會比你少
長不過你的Sandisk
但是有可能長比你少
但是也不會比你差
因為我賺的是半導體的錢
那我就不買這個
但是如果你賺的是信息差
你賺的是對沖基金
或者華爾街
那幫不懂半導體的人
他就要進來買
你要賺那個錢
那就買存儲
存儲就是最快
就兌現這個錢
先給你看到10BP
OK
明白了解了
學習到了
好
不敢不敢
感謝韋文哥
那有沒有下一位
下一位
Messier
或是山寨哥
山寨哥
哈囉
Homer老師
那個
我有一個問題
這是
我看你之前也跟
另外的一些老師有在聊
Nucleo裡面的
Covid5跟Oracle
能不能再詳細的
想一下Nucleo
具體的板塊
以及這兩個個股
你的特別是近期
近期不是Covid5發了財報嗎
近期的一些看法
Covidium
他老是Project Delay
然後我前天上
是跟Femme老師
是跟誰在上面
說要聊過
他的財報的問題
然後我最近也拉了
他財報數據
其實這樣子
就是我們先
首先看到
只是看簡單的CAPEX數據
CAPEX數據
Oracle是沒有停過
它一直在往上長
而且很快
它如果是在
我看看
我那個通往數據
它如果是在
這個24年4Q的時候
它跟Covid5
差的不是特別多
但是
現在在25年4Q的時候
可能是差了3倍吧
那個時候
差不是太多
現在差3倍
所以Oracle
Regardless
大家對於它CDS
質疑或什麼事情
它根本無底線
無差別繼續在投資
然後這個東西
就回復到
我們剛剛講的
AOI和Intel的問題
就是缺不缺嗎
如果是缺的話
投入的人就是會遭
會是過曆早晚
而且一旦過曆就會爆發
那Oracle和Open
你可以把這樣想
Oracle和英偉達
它是直接對於缺不缺Token
然後這些半導體的家伙們
是直接缺不缺配件
包括方伯塊
陳楚
都是缺不缺配件
缺不缺配件
是依附於缺不缺Token
我們是知道它肯定缺Token
所以這些人一定會投入
所以它是會缺配件
但是現在市場定價的差
是缺不缺Token
這個是個問號
這個才是市場的那個東西
為什麼大家會是個問號
就是華爾街開始質疑
左腳踩右腳
你自己投資
然後自己用
這些事情
不管怎麼說
Oracle現在至少
上面的所有存儲的租金
都在上升
這個是毫無疑問
那麼整個我覺得
如果說板塊來說的話
因為其實CPU炒過一輪
我好像是最早說CPU缺貨
我去年就說CPU缺貨
然後GPU最早炒
然後陳楚剛剛講過
光不快
我覺得是持續炒
一直炒下去
然後如果說要新炒的話
可能會在算力中心
就是在Cloud那邊炒一下
然後如果在Cloud爆發的話
那你在那裡面選票的話
選哪張會比較好
我看了一下投入的這個數據
就是我剛剛講
Oracle是一直在投
但是Covip
它沒有
CAPEX數據比較少
但CAPEX數據比較少
它有可能是因為
現金投資率都沒有成功
也不管你想投的錢
反正你project delay
你沒有記錄你的CAPEX
你反正就不能用
就是你能夠用
要完成能用
你投的錢不能用
等於白頭
所以你完成投資
然後能用的這部分的CAPEX
那這個看比率的話
就是Oracle增長是最最明顯
所以如果說
它要從那個算力裡面獲利
它其實6個月
3、6個月調適
就是能夠部署上去
然後再把它租出去
租的時候
還有一個過程
然後調適什麼的
然後可能要短時間
反正一年之內
不需要一年
一年一反一年之內
它肯定會有那個
有財務數據反應的
所以財務數據反應的話
那我們看它往前9個月
3個月過了
或者是12個月過了
那這個東西
你先我們再打掃
不用打掃
你都打掃
我打電話
不好意思
我那個我辦公室的
辦公室來打掃
然後那個
我覺得這3個月
就前面
9個月到12個月來看的話
那9個月到12個月
那個歐洲國的同時很堅決
所以如果說
在在Cloud那邊看的話
我或你覺得歐洲國
那個很棒
我記得去年你11月的時候
當時你有一個
視頻裡面講的非常的精準
就是從擴產的角度來說
從CPU
再到GPU
再到HBM
然後再到
再到GPU
當時你又說到
這是一個一次
從擴產難度來說的一個順序
然後裡面
然後從這個角度來說的話
似乎NewCloud
是最容易的
因為它就是買嘛
對吧
然後從那個價格上來
從股價上來說
似乎NewCloud的這個板塊
是從
從那個時間段來說
到現在是從漲幅來說
漲幅來說也是漲的最少的
是不是可以說
它的未來的潛力
相對於這些半導體的生產商來說
也是更少一點
如果你不是很長時間的話
那你肯定是要買
你不應該去買一個
一直在漲的對吧
這是一個想法
然後第二個就是
擴產沒有那麼容易
就是你做Cloud也沒有
那麼容易
你看看COVID-19Project
得了多少次了
沒有那麼容易
你現在800伏的電
然後你現在模型
越來越大
5T
然後這樣的模型
你需要300MW
這個電廠本身
就是你這個東西的配置
配電和配置也需要很大的
然後並不是
每個地方都可以有這個
有這個電供應的
你選址
這個選址跟大富翁買地一樣
你買掉這個地
然後上面去蓋樓
你地買完沒了
沒有那麼多
我覺得沒有那麼容易
Allocore一直能投出來
是因為人家有經驗
那個Microsoft
你覺得它容易
因為人家老幹這個事情
那人家是Microsoft的
包括整個批文
到後面的執行
那你要一個新的
你看看Copio也不算小公司
那樣子一直在這裡
OK
我再問最後一個問題
大概三週之前
我看浩曼老師當時
也是精準的從CTA的角度
預測了最近
三週的一個大幅的上漲
能不能拍個腦袋
再預測一下
未來比如說一個月
或者是
會不會再回調
或者是一個角度
現在拍不了
因為當時的買盤是很確定的
我是在3月20幾號的時候
我覺得3月底
4月初是肯定要暴漲
因為那個時候看它暴漲
是因為有確定性的買盤
你砸盤砸了一半確定性買盤
那你肯定要暴漲
但是現在沒有這樣的
一個確定性的flow
那我們只能說
現在的Corpus spread
Corpus skill是很大的
也就是你在網上漲的時候
那個call很多
所以你一旦漲的時候
很容易形成Gamma squeeze
Corpus spread
下面的put wall
在變低
也就是有人在那裏賣put
有人在my call
賣put
這個不對稱
賣put的人
就覺得我那裏接貨
不管我接貨
所以往下跌的
其實你看這幾次
往下殺的時候
阻力蠻大的
就是不管你
漲那麼多
你猛跌兩天
Gamma都會有阻力
但這個事情
你有兩面來看
第一個
我都是來被打穿的
你要知道Gamma我這種東西
OPEN我基本都是來被打穿的
所以如果你打穿了那個我
它就會加速的點
或者往下是可以加速的點
所以這是有概率
只是說大概率
它不一定打得動
網上會很容易squeeze
然後但網上squeeze
集中票是非常集中的
就是它的票的位置非常集中
比方說你
你可以去查一下
我前兩天看
前兩天忘了
單票的
比方說美光
Intel
上面的Core很多
就有客人的話
都買那個Core的很多
所以基本上集中在3M上面
都是集中在3M上面
你要squeeze
就要往上漲
需要這個
這個我們叫Longsqueeze
往上漲Longsqueeze的話
也可能是把那個
把3M給它拉上去
其他票我希望不是很大
ok ok感謝我
我沒有問題了
謝謝
沒事
我可以問一個嗎
好的
Hey Herman
首先謝謝那個
謝謝
非常謝謝Herman
我是Eve
都不敢不敢不敢不敢
不敢贏
講得非常非常內
非常非常謝謝Herman
我是想問兩個
相連的問題
兩個相連的問題
第一問題是
如果是那個我
我打比方
比如說Core和Nanthropic
如果是頭部的話
然後整條
整條產業鏈一直下來
到末端比如那個那個那個那個
到末端的
到末端比如說芯片
再往下走
能源
電站
和基建
包括造內
造造造那個機房的
基建
作為一個整個談論
當
當整個AI的那個
潮分狂的時候
Herman你覺得哪一個
點會有最大的增值
這是我第一個問題
第二個問題是
當這個點
有最大增值的時候
我聯繫到你剛才前面說的
就是當缺貨的時候
不是龍一受益
而是龍二受益
就是原來是
原來是輸家受益
這個邏輯
在這樣的情況下
是完全成立的
還是那個具體問題
具體分析
謝謝
我其實不知道
就我也不知道
能不能受益
因為其實我從
我自己的角度來說
你後面並不是缺貨
都應該獲得
PE估值
這是我個人的看法
就比方說
最近很多人在炒零化鷹
就IMP
這個東西
有人在炒零化鷹
那炒零化鷹
我就沒有參與
我早就知道
他們這幫人炒了AXTI
然後
但我也沒有參與
因為我是覺得
你也是個商品
對吧
但確實證明
我是錯的
那家外面
真的把它炒了之類
那個
然後
包括炒電站
炒便店
然後
我覺得這個是傳統的
缺然缺貨
它就是
你能夠把
做便店站的
這個門檻
和做英偉達的門檻比
好像
好像做英偉達的門檻
也更加難語閱
就是你至少
你的MOD
更高
對吧
然後你應該
英偉達你給了我
那個時候
英偉達給我12倍P
但現在可能過一點
然後
然後你現在
那個東西
你要給出
英偉達類似的P
我覺得不大致
就覺得
有點激烈
但是
人家也炒了5倍
所以第一個問題
我可能不太知道
就是他市場有隨機性
然後
這個我不太知道
但我覺得
什麼樣的行業
就是
Loser
能夠
underdog wins
什麼情況下
我覺得是在主線上
主線上的underdog容易贏
要舉個例子
我現在手上送倉的是AMD
然後AMD
我不幫你說
我210塊錢賣的
那我之前的一輪
沒有買他的
我有很多
英討賣費了
我去買了AMD
然後AMD
在GPU上就是個Loser
它是賣不出去的卡
然後缺成那樣
所以人家願意上來
用AMD去調適
Cuda是大家
一起開發調適出來的
你AMD
如果正常情況下
是永遠沒可能追上去的
但是因為缺
所以你可能
能夠賣得掉
然後他在4G度的時候
Meta
那個採購
Opening
有可能能夠幫他做出來
所以我
再加上
我知道
他的那個CPU
那個
在增加份額
英討
減幅還漲那麼多
我想減幅也漲那麼多
你AMD
那怎麼不會比他差
所以我買了
買了很多AMD
然後AMD的原因是這個
就是他是一個Loser
這是主線
他是那個
GPU主線
CPU主線就是英討
然後
然後那個
存儲沒有主線
存儲商品
主線是
荒波快
荒波速度沒有主線
存儲主線
存儲的Loser
是長江和長船
對吧
對
存儲的主線是長江和長船
就是他的Loser
是長江和長船
荒波快是AOI
但是存儲是長江和長船
長江和長船是
他最值得投資的方式
你那個
他上課創版
你就直接
直接Market價錢買進去
你也不用去買那個PE了
我那前兩天我自己買了PE
那我覺得PE還要交稅
他中國很噁心
要交那個
資本利得稅
你要二級市場買
沒有那個東西
就直接直接
存儲直接買進去
他第一天不會漲到位的
明白
謝謝
巴馬老師你好
你好
就是我剛剛
有聽說你
你就是買了那個長江
我也有很多問題
我以前一個一個來
就是我想的
就今年12月
不是Open Eye要上市嗎
然後現在是不是
大家都是在吵預期
因為這個結果
要在12月底
揭曉了
然後包括現在的光
存儲
然後CPU
都是在吵一波
那個預期
然後
到時候
就是Open Eye
真的上市之後
這些會不會冷一下呢
我覺得會
我剛剛不講了嗎
我覺得Open Eye
因為它更加容易
跟上下有聯動了
它稍微預期不到一下
它跌起來
把下面全部拖死了
然後現在
我的倉位
也是在英特爾
然後
我也是就是說
玩的就是
Buy before the news
So on the news
然後但是
它沒有
但是AI這方面
沒有什麼大的那個新聞
主要就是財報
然後財報前
然後我都一直有在買
昨天的大跌
會有在買
你說CPU的話
能吵多久呢
CPU故事為主
跟CPU吵前
市場現在吵CPU
是把它當成存儲吵
CPU是不可能
吵成存儲這樣
就我剛剛講的
存儲在
就是HBM漲的時候
它把DDR給一起帶著
所以你想假設
我英特爾在
因為英特爾
假設英特爾
我像AMD數據我有點忘了
英特爾大概是1米8吧
就是在那個
數據中心的那個業務
和那個PC端業務是1米8
所以算力中心的馬均是到70
如果它把PC的馬均
也搞到70
那不得了了
英特爾這公司
直接飛天了
直接10倍
但是這個東西
不會發生的
這是不可能發生
我告訴你PC賣都賣不掉
現在賣得掉的是
就是搶貨的是那個
這個服務器的CPU
那個是長3倍5倍
那個是有
但是PC端的CPU是賣得賣不掉
那國產
它現在要把那個
國產怎麼寄
國產是沒有
目前國產是沒有
做那個處理器的 對吧
就像CPU
CPU比UV
要UV
UV它做不了
有做
我們不行
不能用
代替這一塊是做不了的
但是國產的長
長那個
長江跟長新的話
就是可以做那個
純屬的代替 對吧
對
對 已經期待了
它的價錢是一樣的
DDR5的價錢是一樣的
我們之前也投過長江跟長新
是
長江是一千一百
一千五百一十七億進的
然後
長新的話是
七百五十億進的
您的價格是在多少呢
我投得比較晚了
我是PRI-PU的
我比你貴
對
但是他們的話是
現在的話
我
因為他們長得太猛了
像長新海地市
他們長得太猛了
我們很懸的
已經報材料了
你放心好了
長新已經報材料了
好的
謝謝何文老師
我最後問題就是
沒事
長新也不用擔心了
長新這公司
還有我說一下
國產的那個滑紅
肯定是比中心好
滑紅大於中心
因為你中國是這樣
所有中國的半導體
你得去投那個做落後之城
做落後之城
它能做得很好
能夠賺錢
但是你要去
把落後之城
做先進之城
你這個是搞邪修
邪修是不會整過的
行
然後像今年的6月
然後
包括12月
然後再疊加
那個特朗普的中期選舉
你覺得就是
會不會有一個回調的機會
然後去倉買入
美國
我不知道
我剛剛在講
我說今年年底
我個人感覺
這幾個
我剛剛前面講了
幾些事情
我覺得這有可能
會共振的
但是
確實不一定
就好像我們在
英特爾業績前
我跟我的分析師說
這個是確定我
好的群裡
好多人都知道
我跟我的分析師說
我說這樣
我們要不要把那個
其他的股票賣掉
等英特爾跌了
就把它買回來
然後
因為我們那個時候
得到的消息
是英特爾的那個
PC端業務很弱
然後這個財報
可能會很差
那最後財報
確實沒有很差
那這件事情
他說為什麼
我們知道財報很差
還是要去
把其他的賣掉
把英特爾留著
就好像不大理智
我說因為不確定
你也不知道
就是我們不能拔准
但是我知道
能夠看得更遠
就是英特爾能夠看得更遠
那我把這個
經歷告訴你
就是
這個就是我們
拔不准
它有可能會發生
這個不好的事情
但是你能看得更遠
你自己決定了
好
那我決定
那我要拿好英特爾
好
那南英特爾
現在這個價
反正你看完
我覺得可能會有些
可能性價比更好的
但是
現在這個價
我就沒法跟你講
因為
我們成本比較低
嗯
我的也還好吧
反正
沒有沒有過90
對
那我看
好
謝謝哈姆老師
拜拜
有沒有
朋友們
還有想
問一下哈姆哥
一些問題
我這邊
還有一個問題
就請問能
能
好了
聽得到嗎
可以
我就是那個
在你那個群裡面
問了一下
那個
對
沒自己看
就是那個
那個
您前面其實也講
sirco就是您覺得
這個東西
其實就是
就是覺得他的
護城河還是比較弱嘛
就是
可能他更加的就是
被這個就是渠道房
控制就比如說
他的那個儲備的收益
就必須要去分給那些
什麼coinbase
什麼之類的
嗯
這個
這個是他的一個
很大的一個弱點
但是現在我發現
很多人在炒這個sirco
他是在炒一個什麼
那些呢
就是說
就因為
因為現在那個
就是跟這個
清洗法案
就很明顯的看到就是
美國的這些管理層
就他們在就是
強迫這些大銀行
就是去必須吃
這口死
就是必須要就是
把這個東西過了
就主要是
可能是那個
就是他們覺得
這個是美在的這個
第二條腿嘛
就是可能就是
這個東西如果是
全面的
爆發之後
就提高對這個
美債的需求
呃
然後這個是一個方面
另外另外一方面就是
華爾街
他可能自己也發現
有優勢了
就是我印象很深刻
就是前面這個
就跟這個
伊朗在打的時候
就有有一個那個交易
所叫那個hyper liquid
然後就他
那些什麼那些
週末的時候
就週末的時候
其他的那些
呃期貨全都停了的時候
就是hyper liquid
上的交易就特別的
這個
發誓的對
然後就可能他們就是
華爾街自己可能也發現這個
就是他如果用這個
穩定幣跟這個區塊鏈
去做這個
就是這個
金融的這個
基礎設施的話
他還是會有一些優勢
比如像那個
24個小時交易啊
然後他的那個就是
呃
迅速的這個確認跟結
結算之類的
對
所以我就覺得
就是說
好像感覺就是
美國的基因層跟這個華爾街
都在
主動的去推動這個
就是穩定幣的一個
爆發嘛
對
然後我就覺得
如果說他是在這樣子一個
就是很高的一個這個
就是
像是
四坦爆
爆發裡面
那麼他的這個
呃
護身盒
稍微比較弱的
的這個缺點能不能
就是說是相對會弱化一些
然後
然後這個是起啊
第二次我覺得現在
就因為
因為我最近在這個
東南亞嘛
就是我去那些什麼
越南亞
然後泰國之類的
就是我我從第一線
我能感受到就是
這個穩定幣在做這個
呃
跨國交易的時候
就比如說你在這邊
你要去付款什麼之類的
以前說你必須要去
依賴這個swift
但是現在的話
就是
如果多換成這個穩定幣之後
他就特別的特別的特別的
這個
快對
所以就就有很多人
他覺得現在投這個
呃
sirkel就有一點那個
就有一點像
就是很早前投那個
微信施付
或者是或者是
施付寶這種感覺
對
就是這個這個
他的優勢
我是能夠切身
體會到的
就他那個
呃這個
sirkel
他在做那個
CPM嘛
就是那個sirkel
payment
對
然後
然後就就可能
可能這方面是不是
會有一個這個
爆發
然後
還有一個方面就是那個
就是剛剛我們其實
講了很多的這個
這個半導體啊
現在還有這種就是
token的這種需求
然後從這裡面
我就覺得其實可以
感受到一個很明顯的點
就是可能
就是以後的這個
人類的經濟
他可能大部分是這個
就是AI
就是在AI
內部去循環
就他有很多東西
其實最後就是
根本就不是賣給
人類了
就是
像我
我們現在做這個半導體
差不多也是
有這樣的邏輯
那麼在這樣子的一個
場景裡面
他的這些
呃
agent的或者說
AI他的這個
經系統
他交易的話
他天然的就是
穩定性就特別適合這個
這個情況
對
就因為你想如果說
他要是用一些
傳統的支付的方式的話
無論是從這個
連接程度
跟這個頻率
還有這個金額
上來講其實都
對不上
但是如果說
你是把它運行在這個
鏈上的話
他可能就會
就天然就適合這種
情況
包括你看
現在他們那個
coinbase
搞了一個那個什麼
呃
一個
一個什麼
402什麼之類的東西
然後他
已經放到那個
就是AWS的這個
Battle Rock上了
所以就是
很多人現在他
不完全是在炒這個
這個Circle的這個就是
儲備手藝
他在炒這個
後面的這些
就是更大的這些敘事
我就想問一下
那個金老師的話
就是
呃
就是說
信不信這個東西
覺得
就是有沒有可能就是
就是比較有
有有有錢儲之類的
謝謝
嗯
我完全不信啊
這些這些故事
我聽過100遍
就是你剛剛講的
故事我都聽過100遍
我完全不信
但是呢完全不信
不代表
你是錯的
就是
你要看你賺的是什麼錢嗎
就我剛剛跟講
那個存儲一樣道理
存儲如果你賺半導體錢
那你就不要去買賺賺
如果你賺的是基金的錢
那你知道
這傻人們要去買
那你就買到他錢
到我覺得解針賺錢
Circle就是這麼一個故事
一樣的
他這些故事
我都完全不行
我一條條跟你講
就第一條
我覺得他要去做USD
T蛋
或者買股美占
你知道那個
整個整個那個Circle的
就數字貨幣增加的是流轉
因為他便捷程度增加的是流轉
他增加的不是交易場景
比方說機器跟機器交易要用
就這個是
所有跟我講的基金經濟
都講這一套東西
機器跟機器交易要用Circle
然後要用用穩定品
就這個這個護城
我倒跟你講
為什麼不是
他增加的流動信誓
比方說我手上有錢
然後我可以快速的用
但是這個效果
跟支付寶可微信沒區別
也就是
我問你一個
你就比方說支付寶可微信
你傳統商戀
你比方說用起來方便
支付寶微信如果有美元
你覺得方便嗎
不是一樣的嗎
必安支付方便嗎
我必安支付到必安帳戶
方便嗎
他要商戀嗎
不商戀
全是中心化解算
那去中心化意義在哪裡
沒有
只是讓它變慢
去中心化意義
在所有解算中間
有一個意義
就是大家認為公認的
它去質疑的中心的記帳者
就是比方說優羅克烈
我不相信優羅克烈
讓大家一起記帳
這個在
反蘭選斯提供的金融記帳
你們不存在
金融記帳
我肯定認優羅克烈
你什麼中心化
去中心化沒有用
這文明認得
然後第二個
去中心化能夠起到的作用
讓你變得更加慢
而不是更加快
中心化記帳一定更快
就是微信支付寶可微用來
直接用美元路過來支付
或者是必安支付
然後用來支付
我就是付到必安的賬賞
然後你有必安賬
我就可以互相支付
那肯定是最快的
所以為什麼
SIR可能幹得過必安
幹不過
跟乾交易所肯定是幹不過的
所以我就不能說服我自己
在你剛才說的兩個點
第三個點
你剛剛講到
買美國國戰
用穩定幣去買美國國戰
這件事情
你知道穩定幣的規模是多少
兩千億
忘了
一千五兩百億
我最近沒看
一千兩百億兩千億
這一波
SIR放出4.5萬億美元
所以
它可以採用的辦法
就是你這個行業
就去關鍵這個行業
然後避開這個行業
就是這個整個有
現有的流動性
對於它來講
杯水射性
也就是說你這個錢
並不是被納入為額外美元
購入美戰
而是說你這個錢
本身就是Money Market
Money Market我剛剛講過了
Soft Rate一天的成交量
是3.1萬億
一天
所以你這個錢
在那裏面杯水射性
根本就倒不了
它考慮的層面
去關鍵的貨幣
還有一個優勢
是什麼呢
灰色制服
黑色制服用的是比特幣
灰色制服是用的USDT
你可以看
就是各種各樣的灰色制服
其實全部用USDT
原來的美元的監管
太嚴
它並不是基礎設施不支持
它是監管不支持
監管太嚴
所以有一些灰色制服可以用USDT
這個確定
有沒有優勢
就有沒有什麼產品
這一點我認
是有的
但是我不認你的competitive advantage
也就是為什麼是你sirco
為什麼不是USDT
你的sirco拿的是一張牌照
是創發兒子的
為什麼創發的女兒
不能再搞
又出來
如果說大家不搞
不搞監管
去監管
那麼可以出來很多張牌照
那我新加坡的牌照
也可以用
也可以用USDT
新加坡可以用USDT
那不能用的話
我新加坡
competitive
可不可以出來
所以這一系列的問題
放在我這裡
我肯定是不會去相信
他這套故事的
哇
還有一個
考料的細節教室
後面我再問一個問題
可以
好
就是剛才講到
整個產業鏈上
這麼多的公司
您覺得
在您所看
因為你剛才不是說到
NVDA的mode
其實是非常非常高
非常非常多樣化
對
您有沒有發現
有其他的在這條
整條鏈上面
有類似這樣的公司
也就是mode其實
非常非常高
但是大家沒有意識到
就沒有pricing
你有pricing
Vidium Pricing
大家都知道
mode很高
然後只是覺得
有人可以追趕
但是其實追趕不了
但其實在
每個西風領域
這個半導體
每個西風領域的mode
都很高
也就是舉個例子
長星和長城
手上有DDR5
對吧
但是他為什麼搞不成
那個HBM呢
因為那個PHY線程
他搞不定
他就搞不定那個
PHY線程
所以他不能變HBM
那你說這個PHY線程
是不是一個mode
是
他就
在每一個小的西風領域裡面
他都有各種gum
所以半導體
最後一旦缺貨的時候
每個有mode的人
都說我贏獎贏獎
這就是現在的行情
但是最最上面
我們說為什麼
是最最頭破
就是他console it
真正提
不是說有mode
因為大家都有
但是
我們要看的是
誰提供了價值
這個價值就是token
誰提供了
更多的token的提高
算力的提高
那肯定是因為
他提高最多
除了
除了那個
除了那個叫什麼
除了那幾個
那個模型公司以外
那肯定是因為他提高最多
明白
那所以他玩贏
好
謝謝
好的
我們再來開放一些問題吧
我可能要
差不多我要下線了
我後面有個事情
我可能下線
我要撤了
Herman哥
那最後最後一個問題
你覺得我們
該做什麼
也跟半導體有關的問題
還有你覺得我們該找誰
我們
我們把這個
女生有點
你有點情
就是有點吵
吵
我們也聽清楚
對不起這樣聽得到嗎
這樣可以
我說Herman哥
對不起
我最後一個問題
你覺得我們
下一期168X這邊
你覺得我們該找
什麼樣的人
然後來講
跟半導體
哪一部分
有關的
有關的議題
這你們開完
你找梁老師去吧
你看梁老師在下面
梁老師
OK
好
今天非常感謝Herman哥
波隆
跟大家來多分享
感謝Herman
感謝
謝謝
好
OK
拜拜
大家
大家有興趣的話
可以加入我們168X的群組
我們會定期分享一些
美股
或是美股一些酷酷的
我們認為
不錯的資產
然後Crypto
我們這邊也看
所以歡迎大家
OK
好
謝謝
謝謝大家
拜拜